Ein weiterer Punkt, der auch ganz wesentlich ist, ist, dass in der Art von Sportjournalismus Fans überhaupt keine Rolle spielen. Dass einfach das, was ja dann den Fußball eigentlich ausmacht und das sind die Zuschauer, dass das eigentlich überhaupt keine Rolle spielt. Und ich glaube, dass der Balesterer da halt auch ein bisschen angetreten ist, um diese Lücke zu füllen und diesen weißen Fleck irgendwie zu beseitigen.
Das war ganz gruselig. Unser Drucker sagte immer, die nächste Rechnung will ich aber voraus. Und es ist tatsächlich so, man hat keine Anzeigen, die Leute kennen einen nicht. Wenn man gesagt hat, man kommt von der Freunde, haben die Leute gedacht, das ist so ein Swinger-Club-Magazin. Also, man hatte Schwierigkeiten, den Leuten begreifbar zu machen, dass man Fußballmagazin ist. Zumal so Fußballkultur, dieses ganze Thema gab es früher einfach noch nicht.
Was müssen das für Zeiten gewesen sein, in denen es das Thema Fußballkultur noch nicht gab? Und damit Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu einem etwas überraschenden Tribünengespräch, Nummer 40 zumindest überraschend für all diejenigen von euch, die mitbekommen haben, dass die Tribünengespräche eigentlich gerade pausieren sollten bis zum Sommer. Aber besondere Zeiten erfordern besondere Umstände. Ihr habt im Intro zwei Personen gehört und die sind nicht zufällig dort gelandet. Beide begrüße ich jetzt bei mir in der Leitung. Zum einen Jakob Rosenberg, seit 2006 beim österreichischen Fußballmagazin Ballesterer und seit 2012 dort als Chefredakteur, jetzt auch immerhin schon im achten Jahr. Schön, dass du mit dabei bist. Und ebenfalls schön, ihn mal wieder im Rasenfunk zu haben. Ich glaube zum ersten Mal seit 2015 wieder Philipp Köster, Chefredakteur und Gründer von 11Freunde und natürlich auch als Philipp Köster auf Twitter zu finden. Hallo Philipp. Sehr schön, dass das geklappt hat. Wir wollen uns heute über Fußballmagazine unterhalten, auch angesichts der aktuellen Probleme, die der Fußball generell gerade hat. Bevor wir aber loslegen mit unserem Tribünengespräch, danke ich noch TK5, Hendrik, Philipp Nähe, der Liverpool-Fan ist und dank des Rasenfunks der Bundesliga noch nicht überdrüssig ist, der lieben D-Serie, Wohles, Sichtmonitor, Krö und Zwei-Spieler-Modus. Sie alle sind Rasenfunk-Supporterinnen und Supporter und halten damit den Rasenfunk-Werbesponsoren und Paywall frei. Dafür herzlichen Dank. Und sie alle sind damit auch Mitglied im Rasenfunk-Supporters Club. Und da ist die Anzeige an dem Ballesterer quasi schon geschrieben, wegen Klaus der Idee. Denn der Ballesterer, das ist unter anderem einer der beiden Anlässe für dieses Tribünengespräch, der hat gerade seinen eigenen Supporters Club gegründet. Jakob, magst du die Hörerinnen und Hörer mal kurz ins Boot holen? Was ist da los bei euch?
Ja, gleich eine komplizierte Frage zum Anfang. Na, es geht im Prinzip darum, Ballesterer ist gerade 20 geworden, wir haben unsere 150. Ausgabe fertig produziert und wir leben seit 20 Jahren in einem schwierigen wirtschaftlichen Umfeld und haben jetzt quasi beschlossen, wir brauchen Unterstützung von unseren Leserinnen und Lesern und haben unter anderem den Ballesterer-Supporters Club gegründet, der uns helfen soll, die Einnahmensituation zu stabilisieren, der uns helfen soll, quasi auch in Zukunft weitermachen zu können. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie weit ich ausholen soll, wie weit der Ballesterer bekannt ist. Wie gesagt, uns gibt es jetzt seit 20 Jahren. Wir operieren in Österreich, Deutschland und der Schweiz vor allem. Das sind unsere drei Heimärkte, wenn man so will. Wir beschäftigen uns mit Fußball und vor allem mit allem, was dazugehört. Fußball in der Gesellschaft, Fußball und Politik, sehr stark auch in Bezug, welche Rolle spielen Fans, welche Stimmen haben Fans, wie werden Fans gehört. Dementsprechend machen wir Journalismus, ist aber Journalismus, der immer an der Grenze der Finanzierbarkeit ist. Es wird so, dass wir schon länger Schulden haben, die auch nicht kleiner werden. Und jetzt haben wir gesagt, wir müssen was tun und wir nutzen den Anlass des 20-jährigen Bestehens, um diese Kampagne zu starten.
Balesterer.at – da bekommt man alle Informationen und kann dann eben euch unterstützen. Du hast es gerade schon angesprochen, euch gibt es seit 20 Jahren und das ist der zweite Anlass für dieses Tribünengespräch. Denn der Balesterer ist 20 Jahre alt, wird 20 Jahre alt und nach allem, was ich recherchiert habe, ist er genau einen Monat älter als die Elffreunde, die nämlich auch 20 Jahre alt werden und die Philipp ein großes Elffreunde-Buch herausgebracht haben, was wirklich groß ist und vor allem wirklich dick und schwer. 456 Seiten. Erzähl uns doch mal, was man da bekommt, wenn man sich das bestellt.
Ja, wir haben ja so ein bisschen versucht, mal eine Werkschau zu betreiben. Also mal zu schauen, was haben wir denn in den 20 Jahren alles so hinbekommen. Und ach, das ist natürlich eine sehr schöne Zeitreise geworden, weil wir sehr, sehr viele junge Spieler gesehen haben, die später mal sehr berühmt geworden sind. Also man sieht Kevin de Bruyne zum Beispiel etwas schüchtern. Sieht aus wie so ein Zwölfjähriger, den man mal aus dem Kinderheim rausgelassen hat. Wie er auf einem kleinen Boot sitzt, wie so ein schüchterner Schuljunge. Wir sehen noch den pickligen Manuel Neuer, den 19-jährigen Mario Götze, der noch keine Ahnung hat, dass er ein Weltstar wird. Wir haben versucht, zu einer Seite 20 Jahre Elfreunde zu beschreiben, mit all den Bildern und all den Reportagen und vielleicht auch ein paar lustigen Aktionen, die wir gemacht haben. Aber vor allen Dingen so eine Revue von 20 Jahren Fußballkultur zu beschreiben. Denn wenn man sich anguckt, wie der Fußball im Jahr 2000 unterwegs war und wie heute, dann erkennt man ihn tatsächlich. Obwohl damals auch die Kommerzialisierung schon echt sehr, sehr weit gedienen war, kaum noch wieder.
Das große Elfreunde-Buch erschienen bei Heine Hardcover. Für 25 Euro gibt es diese 456 Seiten. Und das sind eben so diese beiden Anlässe. Zum einen das 20-jährige Jubiläum von Balesterer und von Elfreunde. Und jetzt dann noch diese konkreten Anlässe. Einmal die Balesterer-Brennt-Kampagne und das Buch, das rausgekommen ist bei Elfreunde. Und wir nehmen das zum Anlass, mal über das große Thema Fußballmagazine zu sprechen. Das steht schon, ehrlich gesagt, sehr lange auf der Liste der Themen für Tribünengespräche. Und da habe ich mit euch beiden ja jetzt die perfekten Gesprächspartner an die Hand bekommen. Könnt ihr euch denn noch erinnern, Jakob, fang du doch mal an, wann du zum ersten Mal einen Fansin oder Fußballmagazin in der Hand gehabt hast.
Ich erinnere mich tatsächlich nicht. Wahrscheinlich irgendwann in meiner Kindheit werde ich irgendwelche Sportzeitungen – oder habe ich ganz sicher viele Sportzeitungen, Fußballzeitungen, weniger, sondern eher generelle Sportzeitungen – gelesen. Ich glaube aber, dass sich meine Geschichte, auch von der von Philipp irgendwie, deutlich unterscheidet, weil ich für diese klassische Fansinkultur vielleicht auch zu jung bin. Also ich habe den Ballestra kennengelernt auch in den ersten oder in frühen Jahren, also ich glaube 2005 oder so. Und da würde ich sagen, das war wahrscheinlich der erste Zugang zu so einer Art von Fußballmagazin. Genau, aber ich habe jetzt nicht die Geschichte, dass ich selber irgendwie in meiner Kurve irgendwie ein Magazin oder ein Fencing gegründet hätte oder so. Und ich habe auch, muss ich zu meiner Schande gestehen, nicht die Geschichte, dass ich immer irgendwie am Bahnhof gewartet habe, bis das nächste Wednesday the day comes kommt und ich das lesen kann.
Muss dich nicht dafür schämen. 1981 bist du geboren, wenn die Informationen, die ich da im Internet finde, richtig sind. Ja, Philipp, dann bist du jetzt hier derjenige, der dir die ganz alten Geschichten auspacken muss. Wann hattest du das?
Hopa erzählt vom Krieg. Ja, es ist ja tatsächlich so, dass ja so Anfang der 90er aufkam, diese ganzen Fanmagazine, wo man sie dann auch in die Hand bekommen hat. Vorher gab es ja nur diese Rauf- und Prügelmagazine wie den Fan-Treff, wo dann immer Hooligans aus allen Städten verkündet haben, dass sie doch die stärksten und die schönsten und die schlagkräftigsten sind. Und dann weiß ich tatsächlich, dass ich als allererstes Mal einen Milan Toror, das war dieses erste deutsche Fänzchen, in die Hand bekommen habe, das da bei St. Pauli produziert wurde. Und mich hat das sofort angesprochen, weil das natürlich eine andere Perspektive war. Vorher hat es da so klassische Sportberichterstattung 1 zu 0, 2 zu 0, wer hat draufgeschossen, wer hat eine rote Karte kassiert. Und das war echt ganz grandios, humorvoll, spannend, punk-rockig, wurde vom Stadion verkauft von Fans, die die gleiche Perspektive hatten wie man selbst. Und tatsächlich ist das dann die Gnade der frühen Geburt, dass ich tatsächlich dann so diese Hochzeit der Fanmagazine mitbekommen habe, wo es wirklich in jedem deutschen und auch österreichischen Stadion so ein Fanmagazin gab, das von Fans gemacht wurde. Wir haben dann ja mit diesem Um halb vier war die Welt noch in Ordnung, in Bielefeld auch eins gegründet, aber es gab auch das Comeback in Düsseldorf, den Millentor Raw, später den Übersteiger, den Splitter, Pippa Millentor und so weiter. Also ganz, ganz viele großartige bunte Hefte. Es ist eigentlich schade, dass es diese gedruckten Magazine nicht mehr in der Fülle gibt, weil das war damals echt großartig. Man konnte in jedes Stadion gehen und bekam immer einen Fansin in die Hand gedrückt.
Und das war ja dann auch der einzige Möglichkeit, an diese Fansins zu kommen. Also man musste aktiver Fan sein, dann sind die einem zwangsläufig über den Weg gelaufen.
Ja, genau. Du kannst natürlich auch tauschen. Es gab ja die große Tauschkultur. Du hast jedes deiner Fanmagazine, wenn sie dann aus dem Copyshop geholt wurden, dann auch an die anderen Leute weitergeschickt. Man war immer extrem beleidigt, wenn das dann in einem anderen Fansin nicht besprochen wurde. Auch die letzten Schrottmagazine wurden dann immer noch hymnisch besprochen, Pflichtkauf und gehört in jedes Bücherregal. Und es war trotz allem eben auch nett, weil sich die Leute dann eben auch untereinander vernetzt haben. Das war vielleicht sogar nochmal das wichtigste Element dieser Fansin-Bewegung, dass du dich immer getroffen hast, dass man sich sofort erkannte an diesen verfrorenen Händen, mit denen man das Fansin hochgehalten hat. Und ich glaube, dass sowas wie das Buffbündnis, also Bündnis der aktiven Fans oder andere Sachen nicht so einfach passiert wären, wenn die Leute sich nicht damals auch über Fansin treffen und über Antirassismus treffen kennengelernt hätten.
Jetzt habt ihr ja beide schon angesprochen, dass damit ja vor allem auch so eine andere Ebene des Fußballs beschrieben wird. Jakob, wenn du jetzt davon sprichst, dass du ein bisschen anders sozialisiert wurdest als Philipp. Philipp war der Bielefeld Dauerkarteninhaber, Allesfahrer und hat da die Welt kennengelernt bzw. Deutschland. Nur Deutschland. Jakob, wie war denn deine Fußballsozialisation und welche Rolle haben denn dann die Themen gespielt, mit denen du dich jetzt dann vor allem auseinandersetzt auch als Chefredakteur?
Ja, jetzt kann ich doch noch auch vom Krieg erzählen. Im Prinzip, ich würde sagen, wahrscheinlich eine ähnliche Fußballsozialisation wie viele andere Kinder, Jugendliche in Wien. Man bekommt irgendwann die Frage gestellt, rapide oder austria und weiß die richtige Antwort. In meinem Fall war das rapide. Ich würde sagen, das große erste Erlebnis war wahrscheinlich die WM 90, wo dann mein Fußballinteresse auch irgendwie gestartet hat. Zu einem Zeitpunkt, wo der Fußball ja auch schon in einem großen Umbruch war mit bald Gründung der Champions League, Premier League und so weiter. Also da war mein erstes so jugendliches, kindliches Fußball, eine Fußballbegeisterung, war dann noch im Stadion. Das ist dann aber auch weniger geworden. In der Pubertät habe ich dann andere Dinge mehr interessiert als Fußball und habe dann bis hier eine Distanz gehalten, war immer wieder mal dort, aber jetzt nicht so total regelmäßig. Und was dann für mich wirklich sehr, sehr viel verändert hat, war, dass ich 2004 und 2005 in Neapel studieren durfte und Napoli damals gerade in die dritte Liga quasi zwangsabgestiegen, vorm Bankrott quasi gerade irgendwie noch gerettet oder neu gegründet und ich das dort sehr stark mitbekommen habe, die Begeisterung dort stark mitbekommen habe und ich mich auch begonnen habe einfach mehr für Fußball wieder zu interessieren. Und das habe ich dann quasi auch wieder, wie ich nach Wien zurückgekommen bin, mitgenommen, habe dann eben auch den Balesterer als so eine Stimme kennengelernt, die da Dinge von Dingen erzählt, die mich auch nochmal speziell interessieren. Also ich habe damals Politikwissenschaft studiert und habe diese Zusammenhänge, all das, was der Balesterer gemacht hat, sehr toll und spannend gefunden und habe dann, würde ich sagen, dann hat sich das alles so gegenseitig irgendwie bedient und verstärkt. Also es ist dann meine Leidenschaft für meinen Verein auch wieder stärker geworden. Mich hat die Arbeit oder das Schreiben für den Balesterer interessiert, mich haben die Möglichkeit noch interessiert, ich dort hart herumzukommen, Leute zu treffen, was auch immer. Und das Ganze war auch verbunden mit dem, was ich eigentlich gerade studiert habe oder was sonst meine Interessen waren. Also zu sagen, wie schaut man auf die Welt, was passiert da. Und ja, so. Fügen sich diese Punkte alle sehr gut zueinander in meiner Fan-Fußball und auch in meiner mittlerweile beruflichen Biografie.
Und ein bisschen ja auch die Aspekte, die im Fußball sonst nicht so beleuchtet werden. Also man erfährt, warum du dich dafür interessiert hast. Aber Philipp, erklär mir mal, das musst du mir jetzt einfach erklären, das ist ja auch alles ganz einfach. Warum war denn das so, dass in den 90ern nur in Fans sind, diese ganzen, ich will jetzt gar nicht sagen Randaspekte, weil für uns sind ja diese Aspekte vielleicht manchmal sogar wichtiger. Als der sonstige Fußball nur dort behandelt worden. Und warum es dann ja fast zeitgleich in Österreich und Deutschland zur Gründung von überregionalen Fußballmagazinen kam?
Ja, ich glaube, da muss man tatsächlich mal so den Urknall dieser ganzen Sache sehen. Der bestritt eigentlich gar nicht in der intellektuellen Aneignung, sondern eigentlich in der Kommerzialisierung des Fußballs. Denn das ist dieses Schicksalsjahr 1992, als die Premier League gegründet wurde, die Champions League aus der Tau verhoben wurde und hier in Deutschland ja auch so ein bisschen diese Kommerzialisierung ins Rollen gekommen ist. Dann gab es Reinhold Beckmann mit der Showtreppe bei Rannensaat 1 Fußball, diesen ganzen die Boßenharmilch und den FC Bayern Löwensenf und was es da alles an kommerziellen Verirrungen gab. Und ich glaube, dass die Fansins nicht anders zu verstehen sind als als Gegenbewegung zu dieser ganzen Kommerzialisierung. Und das war so die Zeit, in der sich Werner Lorand vom Münchner Olympiaturm per bungee-Seil gestürzt hat, wo es den Fuchs gab für den besten Nachwuchsspieler, also dieser ganze Quatsch, der da rund um den Fußball veranstaltet wurde. Und ich glaube, all die, die schon immer zum Fußball gegangen sind, brauchten quasi so eine Art Gegenöffentlichkeit. Also es gab das Marktschreierische und es gab den biederen Sportjournalismus. Und ich glaube, die Fans haben sich immer weniger repräsentiert gefühlt. Und daraus entsprang dann tatsächlich zunächst diese Fansien-Generation, also diese ganzen lokalen Magazine. Und ich glaube, als nach fünf Jahren dieser Hype vorbei war, als alle lokalen Magazine dann schon ihre Erfahrungen gemacht hatten, ihre Hefte gemacht haben, dann gab es, glaube ich, so eine ganze Menge Leute, die sich überlegt haben, was machen wir denn jetzt eigentlich? Gehen wir in den normalen Journalismus oder gehen wir zu den überregionalen Zeitungen oder gründen wir selber Magazine? Und deswegen war es, glaube ich, durchaus nicht zufällig, dass sowohl die Kollegen Reinhard Grenhuber und Federmeyer in Österreich mit dem Ballesterer, als auch Reynaldo und ich in Deutschland, als auch Offside in Schweden und so weiter und so fort sich alle dann überlegt haben, bevor wir jetzt quasi so versuchen, klassische Journalisten zu werden, machen wir doch lieber unser eigenes Heft. Weil wir ja auch gesehen haben, glaube ich, alle, dass der Bedarf da war.
Ja, ich würde da gerne noch ergänzen. Ich glaube, dass das alles total stimmt. Also ich glaube auch, das ist ein bisschen so ein dialektisches Verhältnis quasi. Also es gibt die Kommerzialisierung und diese Magazine sind auch ein bisschen eine Reaktion darauf oder werden auch dadurch überhaupt erst ermöglicht. Und ich glaube, was ein zweiter Faktor ist, ist, dass sich natürlich auch die technischen Möglichkeiten verändert haben. Also es war plötzlich leichter möglich, Dinge abzustimmen. Also ich meine, das Internet war Anfang der 2000er Jahre relativ neu, aber das war was, was ja auch gerade diese Magazine auch stark genutzt haben und zu sagen, ok, man berichtet von anderen, von Ebenen, die man vorher gar nicht gekannt hat. Oder man hat halt irgendwie den Computer zu Hause, auf dem man irgendwie Texte irgendwie schreiben kann, wo man einfach so was wie Microsoft Word oder sowas, wo man einfach nicht die Schreibmaschine bedienen muss, sondern wo man einfach am Computer was schreiben kann. Das war ja auch da grad auch relativ neu, dass es das alles gibt. Und ich glaube, es hat da ja auch verschiedene Arten gegeben, wie man auf den modernen Fußball und auf die Kommerzialisierung, dass der Fußball größer wird, dass er breiter wird, dass mehr Leute auch dort sind, reagieren. Und ich würde sagen, die Fansins oder dann auch die Magazine waren das eine. Und das andere waren natürlich auch die, die Leute lesen. Also grad auch die Ultra-Bewegung, die ja auch zu dem Zeitpunkt in Österreich, in Deutschland, wo sich die ersten Gruppen gegründet haben und so weiter, die das dann auch wieder gegenseitig gelesen haben oder sich da irgendwie eingebracht haben und so weiter. Also da ist so ein eigener Bereich von, nennen wir es, größer Gegenkultur entstanden. Mit halt verschiedenen Strömungen und verschiedenen Bereichen drin.
Klingt so ein bisschen wie die manchmal auch als Vorwurf vorgebrachte These, dass das Fußballpublikum sei akademischer und kultureller geworden. Und dann war das halt so eine Nebenerscheinung, dass man auch auf einmal wohl formulierte Texte über Fußball gerne gelesen hat.
Ja, glaube ich auch. Also wir haben ja quasi immer so eine Kornbys Fieberpitsch, dass er schon 92 oder 91 erschienen ist, so als als literarische Wiederentdeckung gesehen. Und natürlich gab es, glaube ich, so eine Skepsis der Intellektuellen, die begegnet einem sogar hin und wieder heutzutage noch, dass die Leute, also gerade das Intellektuelle, die dann ja die die Masse und das Publikum und die niederen Instinkte eher eher eher suspekt sind so. Ich glaube aber tatsächlich, wie Jakob das auch sagt, dass es ein vielschichtiges Phänomen ist, also was wir da ja so in den letzten 20 Jahren erlebt haben, ist ja auch ein unglaublicher Boom des Fußballs. Also wenn du siehst, dass sich alle anderen sozialen Milieus langsam auflösen, also diese Politikmilieus, die religiösen Milieus, die wir früher hatten, katholisch, evangelisch und so weiter, das ist alles in Auflösung begriffen und der Fußball ist so ein bisschen an die Seite derer gesprungen. Also ich glaube, es gibt fast heutzutage keinen gesellschaftlichen Akteur mehr, der so viele Leute begeistert, jedes Wochenende und auch unter der Woche. Und dann ist es ja fast logisch, dass du dort ganz viele unterschiedliche Formen dieser Kultur hast und dass es dann natürlich auch Magazine gibt, die diese Kultur abbilden.
Ja und vielleicht noch zwei Sätze zu den Intellektuellen. Also da finde ich es vor allem auch interessant, dass das was ist, was ja eigentlich ein total deutschsprachiges Phänomen ist, dass man sagt, okay, die Intellektuellen sind weit weg. Also ich war in Österreich, das war in Deutschland so, aber wenn man nach Lateinamerika oder nach Italien schaut, ist das gar nicht der Fall. Also da war diese Verbindung von Fußball und Künstlern, Literaten, war es auch immer stärker. Ich glaube, was ein zweiter intellektueller Aspekt ist, der auch wichtig war für Magazine, wie uns auf jeden Fall, ist, dass der Fußball durch diese ganze Kommerzialisierung und dadurch, dass er größer geworden ist, auch plötzlich ein Gegenstand von so was wie sozialwissenschaftlicher oder ökonomischer Forschung geworden ist. Speziell bei uns als total wichtiges Phänomen die ganze Frage der Aufarbeitung des Nationalsozialismus, also wie welche Rolle hat denn der Fußball oder haben solche Bereiche wie der Sport im Nationalsozialismus gespielt. Das heißt, es gibt plötzlich neue Felder, die sich für den Fußball interessieren und die dann natürlich auch Organe brauchen oder Plattformen, wo sie das dann unterbringen können. Da sind dann so Magazine wie El Freunde und der Balesterer dann halt auch ein ein toller Verstärker gewesen. Also einerseits haben wir von diesen Entwicklungen in anderen Bereichen total profitiert, andererseits haben die uns gebraucht, um sich auch weiter zu entwickeln, weil wir halt die Ersten waren, die sowas auch einen Platz gegeben haben.
Das ist eine sehr gute Anmerkung, auch was eben den besonders deutschsprachigen Umgang mit dem Fußball angeht, dass man sich da als jemand, der intellektuell ist, gerade eben nicht mit diesem Sport beschäftigen wollte, wo ich mir dann die Frage stelle, warum war das dann vor allem in England auch so anders und England nenne ich jetzt deshalb, weil da ja dann das erste überregionale Fußballmagazin tatsächlich herkommt, nämlich When Saturday Comes, der Name ist vorhin schon gefallen, 1986 von Andy Lyons gegründet und damit ja weit, weit vor eben Fußballmagazinen wie eben Elffreunde und Ballesterer. Wie erklärt ihr euch denn, dass man da dann schon anders über Fußball reden und schreiben konnte und dass Leute gelesen haben?
Ich glaube, dass das natürlich einerseits mit dieser doch sehr, sehr regen Fanszenenkultur in England zu tun hatte. Also dort war es ja noch mehr als in Deutschland so, dass du gerade aus dem Punk- und Skin-Bereich sehr, sehr viele Magazine hattest. Also wirklich eine ganz, ganz lebendige Kultur. Insofern war da auch der Boden bereitet, um zu sagen, das probieren wir jetzt eben auch mal im Fußballbereich. Ich glaube auch, dass Andy und Mike, die jetzt 86 dann ja wirklich so Neuland betreten haben, viel vorgegriffen haben, dem was dann später anderswo passiert ist. Und es ist ja ganz lustig, also wenn man heute so Andy dann nach London fährt und sich in den Redaktionsräumen anguckt, dann hat man auch ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass die Zeit dort stehen geblieben ist. Das ist ein ganz schönes Phänomen. Man kann sich vorstellen, dass sie 86 oder 89 schon in den gleichen Räumen gearbeitet haben. Also dieser Fan-Scene-Gedanke, dieser Gedanke, wir machen uns unsere eigene Meinung. Der ist ja bei Wednesday, der kam ganz stark. Ich glaube, die haben bis heute ja kein einziges Interview geführt, was wir bei Elfreunde und beim Ballester ja sehr häufig machen. Einfach um zu sagen, das ist unsere Perspektive, das ist die Perspektive der Anhänger, das ist die Perspektive der Leute aus den Kurven. Also ich glaube schon, dass das so ein Gedanke ist, der in England einfach viel präsenter war und möglicherweise dann eben auch schon in den 80ern dazu geführt hat, dass die Leute gesagt haben, jetzt machen wir dieses Magazin und gucken mal, wie es passiert und wie es kommt.
Ja und ich glaube, dass der englische Fußball gerade in den 80ern, also alles, was da Philipp sagt, unterschreibe ich voll, glaube ich auch. Und ich glaube, dass der Fußball selber dort auch Entwicklungen hatte und die Gesellschaft, die ja auch mit anderen europäischen Ländern auch nur bedingt vergleichbar war. Also wenn man sich die ganzen Diskussionen über den Hooliganismus oder Fetcher anschaut, was da auch an Kulturen, an Strukturen, also mit der Zerschlagung der Gewerkschaftsbewegung und so weiter, was da alles im Umbruch war, gesellschaftlich glaube ich, dass sich da auch noch mal neue neue Räume auch eröffnet haben.
Und wo würdest du, Philipp, dann den Unterschied zwischen einem Fan-Scene und einem Fußballmagazin ziehen?
Ich glaube, ein Fan-Scene hat ja per se erstmal einfach den Status des ehrenamtlichen. Also man macht das, man trifft sich in seiner Freizeit, trinkt Bier, schnipselt was früher per Microsoft Word, später mit ein paar Layout-Programmen zusammen und guckt, dass irgendwie am Vorabend des Erscheins dann noch alles zusammengekleppelt wird. Dann rennt man in den Copyshop und am nächsten Morgen oder am nächsten Nachmittag verkauft man es vom Stadion und hofft, dass es genügend angetrunkener Anhänger gibt, die das Ding kaufen und es nicht für die Stadionzeitung halten. Das würde ich mal so als Wesenskern des Fan-Scenes, also des ehrenamtlichen Fan-Scenes bezeichnen. Ich glaube, sowohl bei Reinhard und Klaus beim Ballestra als auch bei uns bei 11Freunde war es tatsächlich schon auch der Impuls zu sagen, wir wollen auch schon davon leben können, das soll unsere Arbeit werden. Also wir wollen nicht mehr jeden Morgen um neun, aber wir wollen regelmäßig daran arbeiten, wir wollen diesen Magazin rausgeben, wir haben einen inhaltlichen Anspruch, sagen wir wollen was erzählen, aber wir wollen uns auch professionalisieren. Also ich glaube gerade die Professionalisierung, das regelmäßige, verlässliche Erscheinungstermine, also ich weiß, dass wir bei unserem Fan-Magazin mal alle vier Wochen, mal alle acht, mal alle zwölf Wochen rausgekommen sind. Also die Professionalisierung und Verlässlichkeit in allen Bereichen ist, glaube ich, ein Wesenskern dessen, dass man sagt, man macht so ein Fußballmagazin und nicht nur ein Fan-Scenes. Also kann man Kommerzialisierung nennen, wenn man das tatsächlich ausschließlich negativ betrachten will. Ich glaube aber, dass das allererste erste Mal Professionalisierung ist, weil Kommerzialisierung würde ja auch bedeuten, dass du das Gewinnstreben über alles stellst. Das würde ich weder beim Ballestra noch bei Elf-Freunde als Wesenskern des Magazins bezeichnen.
Da habe ich deutlich überspitzt, das stimmt natürlich. Wie wichtig ist dann auch dieses sich-los-lösen von der Perspektive eines Vereins? Also um halb vier war die Welt noch in Ordnung, eurem Bielefeld-Fansin ging es logischerweise um Bielefeld und Bielefeld und um Bielefeld und die Arminia. Und dann eben die zugeschickten anderen Fansins, die alle hochgelobt wurden. Aber ist das auch noch ein wesentlicher Aspekt, dass die Masse an Fußballfans, die sich nur für einen Verein interessiert, die gibt es natürlich, aber dass es an deren Rand quasi auch Fans gibt, die durchaus auch die Perspektive den größeren Blick haben und dass das dann eher über Fußballmagazine erfüllt werden konnte, dieses Interesse als über Fansins?
Also glaube ich ganz sicher, wir haben das tatsächlich auch schon zu den Bielefelder Zeiten gemerkt und gelernt, dass es doch relativ viele gab, die sich auch interessiert haben für schottische Zweitligisten, für Auswärtsfahrten, für andere Kulturen, einfach weil der Wissensbedarf doch sehr, sehr groß war und weil man das auch nirgendwo anders lesen konnte. Aber das war natürlich für Elfreunde am Anfang durchaus auch eine Herausforderung, um zu schauen, dass man noch mal Verbindungen in die anderen Städte knüpft, dass man möglichst wenig über den eigenen Verein schreibt und versucht, möglichst viele unterschiedliche Perspektiven zu Wort kommen zu lassen. Ich glaube, wir haben es damit fast sogar übertrieben, also wir haben tatsächlich, glaube ich, in den ersten 30 oder 40 Ausgaben nur ein einziges Mal über Arminia Bielefeld berichtet, um uns nicht diesen Vorwurf auszusetzen, wenn wir jetzt auf Arminia fixiert seien. Also ich glaube, die Leute mussten sich dran gewöhnen. Also unser einziger Anzeigenkunde der ersten drei Jahre, nämlich Herforder Pilz, hat am Anfang immer noch gedacht, wir wären ein Bielefelder Magazin und war dann irgendwann total sauer, als er merkte, dass gar nichts über Arminia drin ist und hat dann die Anzeigen storniert. Also wir mussten schmerzhaft lernen, dass das durchaus irgendwie erst mal vermittelt werden musste, dass man jetzt nicht mehr über Arminia schreibt, sondern über ganz, ganz viele andere Vereine, die es auch ganz spannend und aufregend in der Liga und anderswo gibt.
Also aber im Grunde hast du jetzt auf eine sehr höfliche Art und Weise gesagt, dass das, was ich gerade in meiner Frage formuliert habe, komplett falsch ist. Weil ihr habt eben nicht nur über Arminia gesprochen.
Nein, gar nicht. Also es ist auch tatsächlich so, dass es natürlich, gerade wenn wir so Beiträge aus der Ich-Perspektive haben, wo wir uns noch mal nostalgisch an früher erinnern, hin und wieder natürlich auch immer wieder Arminia vorkommt, aber ansonsten spielt Bielefeld und spielt dieser ganze alte Kosmos in der Berichterstattung von Elf-Freunde echt nur eine untergeordnete Rolle. Weil wir uns auch gedacht haben, kann man natürlich immer machen und dann gibt es wahrscheinlich die 50 Kollegen von früher, die das auch wahnsinnig spannend finden in Bielefeld, aber alle anderen winken dann ja auch ein bisschen langweilig ab, wenn man nur noch die alten Geschichten immer wieder erzählt. Insofern sind die Leute immer schon fast ein bisschen ausgehungert, also die alten Kameraden. Aber ich glaube, es ist ganz gut, dass wir uns da selber etwas beschränken.
Und was wusstest du damals, Philipp, über Vertrieb und Gestaltung eines Magazins?
Gestaltung war natürlich ohnehin eher so das Fähbeil vom Kollegen Rinaldo Cudu, der das mitgegründet hat. Der Vertrieb war noch ein bisschen schmerzhafter, weil wir natürlich die naive Vorstellung hatten, wir könnten das einfach vom Stadion verkaufen. Und das hat überhaupt nicht funktioniert, weil die Leute, gerade bei bundesweiten Magazinen, überhaupt keinen Grund haben, das vom Stadion zu kaufen. Da interessieren sie sich für die Stadion-Zeitung oder das eigene Fanmagazin. Da braucht kein Mensch Freunde, das so zu kaufen. Und als wir dann versuchten, das in den Kiosk hineinzubringen, das haben die Kollegen vom Balesterer auch dann später mal gemacht, ging es natürlich schon auch für uns stark darum, irgendwie wenigstens an den Banus-Buchhandlungen präsent zu sein. Haben uns dann verschiedenen Vertrieben an den Hals geworfen. Einer ist dann sofort pleite gegangen und hat dann noch, glaube ich, die dringend benötigten 2000 Euro, die wir hätten brauchen müssen, dann irgendwie noch vergesellschaftet und das haben wir dann auch nie wieder. Also es ist tatsächlich ein schwieriger Markt. Also es ist sehr, sehr schwierig, diese Magazine dann immer so problemlos in die Kioske reinzubekommen, aber ich glaube, da lernt man einfach dazu. Also ganz am Anfang waren wir alle so blutige Amateure, aber ich glaube, sowohl die österreichischen Kollegen als auch wir haben inzwischen dann so ein etwas mehr Know-how, worauf man achten muss, wenn man so ein Magazin an die Kioske bringen will.
Von 200, die ihr mitgenommen habt von der Ausgabe Nummer 1, die jetzt natürlich heiß begehrt ist, habt ihr 192 wieder mit zurückgenommen vom Berliner Olympiastadion.
Grauenhaft! Acht Stück haben wir verkauft und sechs wurden noch zurückgebracht, weil sie dachten, es sei die Stadionzeitung. Es war auch echt deprimierend, weil wenn 40.000 bis 50.000 besoffene Bremer und Bayern-Fans an dir vorbeiziehen und kein einziger will dieses Heft, dann zweifelt man ja zwischendurch schon mal an der Geschäftsidee. Aber wie gesagt, das war der große Fehler zu glauben, dass die Leute vom Stadion oder im Stadion was anderes brauchen als Bier, Bratwurst und vielleicht das lokale Fanmagazin.
Schlechtes Zielgruppenmarketing, aber da lernt man ja dann mit dazu. Jakob, du warst ja damals noch nicht persönlich involviert, hast du ja schon gesagt. Ich gehe aber mal davon aus, dass du auch viel gehört haben wirst, nachdem du ja auch schon dann sehr früh beim Ballesterer mit dabei warst. Wie kann man dann jetzt verglichen damit? Also wir haben Freunde, zwei Menschen, Reinhard Kodu und Philipp Köster, die stehen vor einem Olympiastart und versuchen irgendwie, die Freunde loszuwerden. Wie war es denn beim Ballesterer? Vor welchem Stadium stand man denn da und ist verzweifelt?
Ja, ich würde sagen, verzweifelt waren wir vor allem bei den Spielen des Nationalteams. Und sonst ist es aber eigentlich gegangen. Also das Stadionverkauf war gerade in den ersten Jahren, glaube ich, sehr wichtig. Auch weil man nicht dort gestanden ist, um was zu verkaufen, sondern weil die Kollegen davor gestanden sind, die Zeitungen angeboten haben, dann ins Stadion gegangen sind, dann wieder rausgegangen sind und wieder verkauft haben. Das heißt, die Leute waren ja auch bekannt in ihren Kurven. Also sie sind dort hingegangen, wo sie auch normalerweise auch ohne Magazin hingehen würden oder ohne Zeitung hingehen würden. Und ich glaube, dass das was ist, was für Balesterer immer total wichtig war und auch wichtig ist, dass wir ein Magazin sind, das aus Stadion gern besteht und wo dann irgendwie das Umfeld, ob das die Kurve ist oder die Längsseite, was auch immer, dann ja auch weiß, okay, das ist ja von Balesterer. Und man gehört auch sonst dazu, also man versucht jetzt nicht den Leuten nur irgendwas reinzudrucken. Und ich glaube, dass das wichtig war. Und klar ist aber auch Stadionverkauf etwas, was sehr schwierig ist. Das merken wir jetzt auch, wenn wir es hin und wieder mal machen. Die Leute wollen einfach im Stadion nicht lesen, verstehe ich auch. Also das ist halt, geht vielleicht nach dem Spiel, dass man sagt, okay, man nimmt sich eine Zeitung mit für die U-Bahn oder für einen Heimweg oder was weiß ich was. Aber eigentlich ist das dort nicht das erste Thema. Und ich glaube, dass es gut ist, das auch hin und wieder zu machen, weil ich auch glaube, dass es halt auch eben diese Nähe zeigt oder weil es ja auch zeigt, okay, ich bin beim Ballesterer. Das heißt, wenn Leute Feedback haben, wenn sie sagen, okay, was schreibt sie für einen Scheiß oder super Geschichte letztes Mal, was auch immer, dass sie das auch irgendwie loswerden können. Aber so als Geschäftsmodell, glaube ich, ist der starken Verkauf, reicht das nicht.
Leserbriefe in der Realität, da stelle ich mir ehrlich gesagt spannend vor zumindest manchmal so ein bisschen. Was wir ja auch schon im Intro gehört haben, ist, dass die Fußballmagazine auch die Berichterstattung erweitern. Philipp hat es vorhin auch schon mal genannt. Das gab quasi trocken und bieder und es gab völlig überdreht und aufgeheizt. Und vor allem die Perspektive der Fans spielte aber in den klassischen Medien kaum eine Rolle. Jetzt kamen Fußballmagazine wie eben Freunde und wieder Ballesterer und haben diese Perspektive ergänzt. Haben denn Philipp die Fußballfans denn auch gleich verstanden, was da eigentlich der Mehrwert ist an diesen neuen, heute würde man sagen, Playern?
Ja, glaube schon. Natürlich gab es so verschiedene Entwicklungsschritte, glaube ich, in beiden Magazinen. Es gab dann tatsächlich größere Öffentlichkeit, dadurch, dass es das Internet gab. Sicherlich war in Deutschland auch die WM 2006 ein großer Boost für die Aufmerksamkeit. Aber ich glaube, was relativ schnell klar gewesen ist, zumindest auch bei 11Freunde, war, dass das so eine andere Art von Fußballjournalismus sein will. Ob man diesem Anspruch immer gerecht geworden ist, weiß ich gar nicht. Man selber verklärt ja auch immer gerne mal die frühen Jahre und die frühen Hefte und stellt dann fest, dass vieles von dem, was man damals geschrieben hat, heutzutage eher nicht mehr den Weg ins Blatt gefunden hätte, weil es jetzt auch so lustig und so spannend und so innovativ auch nicht war. Aber ich glaube, dass das damals tatsächlich dann um 2000 immer noch relativ neu war. Also wenn man sich mal heute anschaut, wie viel Hochqualität, wie Fußballjournalismus es gibt, wie differenziert die Medienlandschaft ist, was für unterschiedliche Darstellungsformen es auch gibt. Es gibt so viele großartige Blogs, Internetpräsenzen. Guckt euch mit dem Rasenfunk an, welche eigene Welt ihr da geschaffen habt mit den anderen Podcasts zusammen. Also das hat sich ja unfassbar differenziert und heutzutage kann man unfassbar viele Sachen, schlaue Sachen, spannende Sachen über 30 verschiedene Fachgebiete im Fußball lesen. Das gab es einfach damals nicht. Das muss man sich wirklich nochmal klar machen. Es gab Fanmagazine, viele davon wurden dann so um 98, 99 auch eingestellt. Und dann kamen halt wir und schlossen diese Lücke. Also die Leute wollten ja was über Fußball lesen, wollten was Lustiges, Spannendes, intelligente Sachen lesen, andere Perspektiven, erfrischende Perspektiven. Und ich glaube, dass deswegen das auch bei allem, was man sich selber jetzt mal so auf die Schulter klopft und sagt, hey, super, dass wir diese Ideen hatten, super, dass das alles so gelaufen ist, war die Zeit auch reif. Und es war auch eben Glück, dass einerseits der Fußball so boomte, dass man diese Präsenz hatte, dass sich so viele Leute darauf gestürzt haben. Und außerdem, das muss man eben auch nochmal sein, dass es überhaupt noch möglich war, neue Magazine an den Kiosk zu bringen. Also ich glaube, wer heutzutage sagen würde, ergründet sowas wie den Ballesterer oder WL-Freunde, der bekäme zu Recht einen Vogel gezeigt. Weil es heutzutage viel, viel schwieriger wäre, so ein Magazin zu etablieren.
Jakob, denkt dich, sind es auch so mit deiner Einschätzung, wie die Medienlandschaft in Österreich war, rund um die Jahrtausendwende, dass da eben einfach diese Lücke bestand, in die man reingehen konnte?
Ja, die Lücke war da. Ich würde sagen, die Lücke ist auch immer noch da. Also sie hat sich verändert. Ich würde auch sagen, es hat sich verändert. Ich glaube, dass da Magazine wie wir und Freunde da wichtig waren. Ich glaube aber auch, dass sich der Fußballjournalismus generell enorm verändert hat. Einfach dadurch, dass sich auch der Fußballkonsum verändert hat. Heutzutage ist es so, du hast irgendwie alle Möglichkeiten, mehr oder weniger jedes Spiel der Welt um jede Zeit, mehr oder weniger live zu sehen. Selbst wenn du es nicht siehst, hast du live Dicker, hast innerhalb kürzester Zeit irgendwelche Berichte dazu, weißt, du siehst die wichtigsten Szenen, was weiß ich, ein paar Stunden später auf YouTube oder wo auch immer. Die Zeit ist viel schneller geworden im Journalismus oder in der Berichterstattung über Fußball oder im Konsum von Fußballberichterstattung. Ich glaube, dass sich deswegen sowohl Medien wie unsere, aber auch klassische Tageszeitungen, klassische Medien überlegen müssen, wie gehen sie anders auf die Situation ein und wie können sie auf das neu reagieren. Sie müssen mehr auf Hintergründe setzen, sie müssen andere Dinge erzählen, weil ein Matchbericht von gestern im Residium der Zeitung heute niemanden mehr. Das heißt, man muss was anderes erzählen und damit schafft man es halt auch, dass es quasi so informierte Kreise oder informiertere Kreise gibt und dass das Ganze insgesamt auf ein höheres Niveau gehoben wird. Wo ich mir nicht sicher bin, ist bei dieser Fanperspektive, ich glaube, dass es sehr viele Medien gibt, von Fans selber, ob das jetzt Blogs sind oder irgendwelche anderen Fans sind, die sich direkt an die Fans vielleicht wenden. Generell würde ich sagen, sind Fans in der Berichterstattung nach wie vor total unterrepräsentiert. Das liegt einerseits an den Medien, die oft keinen leichten Zugang haben. Also die sind vielleicht sich auch gar nicht so sehr interessiert dafür, was motiviert einen Kurven, was wollten die überhaupt, was haben die für Probleme. Weil diejenigen, die darüber berichten sollten, interessieren sich halt eher dafür, wie schneller Spieler ist oder wie in dem Sinne der Torquote ist oder was auch immer, weil das ihr enges Feld quasi ist. Also dann zu sagen, ich schaue jetzt von der Presse-Tribüne rüber auf die Fan-Tribüne, das ist schon ein relativ weiter Weg, den man gehen muss. Gleichzeitig ist es halt auch so, dass sich Fans relativ schnell mal missverstanden fühlen oder gerne missverstanden fühlen und auch da, würde ich sagen, im Normalfall nicht den engen Austausch mit Medien suchen. Und ich glaube, dass das ein Bereich ist, der gerade für uns halt auch extrem wichtig ist, weil wir versuchen, die Fansperspektive oder Stimmen von Fans bei Geschichten einfach immer drin zu haben als wichtigen Bestandteil des Sports und ich glaube, dass das was ist, was sich trotz der Ausdifferenzierung vom Fußballjournalismus noch wenig geändert hat.
Ist es nicht irgendwie seltsam, dass man bei allem Boom, den man in der Fußballlandschaft hat, und du kannst ja inzwischen, also jetzt gerade natürlich nicht wegen Corona, aber du kannst normalerweise sehr leicht durch eine Woche kommen und an jedem Tag mehrere Fußballspiele konsumieren und auch mehrere zigtausend Medien, die darüber berichten, dass dann ausgerechnet dieser große Teil des Fußballs, nämlich all das, was quasi direkt neben dem Feld passiert, nämlich auf den Rängen, dass der so ausgeblendet wird, weil es stimmt ja, was du sagst, dass man jetzt auch anders über Fußball schreiben muss, weil es eben nicht mehr reicht zu sagen, am nächsten Morgen um acht, ach ja, übrigens gestern fiel in der 73. Minute das 2 zu 1 nach einem Eckball, sondern weil man eben hintergründlich schreiben müsste, ich verstehe das ehrlich gesagt immer so gar nicht, warum dieser riesige Teil des Fußballs, nämlich die Fankultur, so selten Beachtung findet oder immer nur dann, wenn es halt verbunden ist mit einem Skandal.
Ich glaube halt, dass eine der großen Ängste, die die etablierten Medien haben, ist, dass sie die Fankultur gar nicht verstehen. Also diese Fankultur ist ja Jugendkultur und die ist mal schroff, die ist oft verletzend, die testet Grenzen aus, die ist wild. Und ich glaube, dass viele dann das erstens nicht verstehen, zweitens Angst davor haben, drittens natürlich auch Klischees aufsetzen, wie dem, dass es in den Stadien immer gewalttätiger zugeht. Und ich glaube all das führt dazu, dass du einerseits natürlich diese Bilder ganz faszinieren findest und jeder Sponsor nutzt sie gerne, um ihr seine Wettangebote zu verkaufen. Und Sky würde wahrscheinlich auch kein Abo verkaufen, wenn sie nicht zwischendurch auch nochmal tobende Fankurven zeigen würden. Aber ich glaube, die Beschäftigung damit, auch das Akzeptieren, dass dort auch Dinge passieren, die man nicht versteht, die machen inmitten von so einer riesigen Entertainmentindustrie, die ja wirklich drauf gepolt ist, dass alles funktioniert, alles beherrschbar, alles berechenbar ist, vielen Leuten eher Angst. Und deswegen glaube ich schon, dass es nach wie vor für viele Leute ihren Bremdesgebiet ist. Ich finde, das sieht man ja tatsächlich auch in der ganzen Diskussion, die wir kurz vor Corona hatten, also diese Eruption rund um Dietmar Hopp, dass es da gar keine Bereitschaft gibt, gerade auch von Funktionären, von Leuten, die sich eigentlich damit auskennen müssten, sich auch nur ansatzweise damit auseinanderzusetzen, was da gerade in den Kurven passiert.
Ja, also ich würde dem auch zustimmen. Ich glaube, das es noch eine Ebene dazu gibt, nämlich, dass Fans – und wir haben das ja auch schon öfter besprochen – die ganze Kommerzialisierung des Fußballs, der Fußball hat sich komplett verändert heute und im Vergleich zu vor 20 Jahren. Ich glaube, was man als Konstante auch sehen kann, es wird Fans immer wieder oder immer mehr gesagt, ihr spielt es eigentlich eh keine Rolle. Also es wird den Leuten, es wird ja auch gesagt, okay, es geht darum, wir brauchen höhere TV-Einnahmen, wir brauchen bessere Sponsoring-Einnahmen, wir müssen unsere Einnahmen noch diversifizieren. Und klar, Matchday-Einnahmen sind auch wichtig, aber eigentlich da ist vor allem wichtig, dass man Skyboxen hat und so weiter. Also das ist so die Entwicklung, die passiert. Das heißt, es gibt so eine generelle Abwertung von dem, was Fans für ein Spiel bedeuten, die halt total massiv ist. Und aus dem folgt ja dann auch wieder mehreres. Also nämlich einerseits zum Beispiel, dass eigentlich die wichtigsten Berichterstatter im Fußball mittlerweile Unternehmen sind, die ein Produkt verkaufen wollen, nämlich ihre Fernsehrechte. Das heißt, das ist eigentlich der Großteil von Fußballberichterstattung besteht aus Rechteinhabern, die sagen, wir verkaufen jetzt die Deutsche Bundesliga oder die Österreichische Bundesliga oder die Serie A oder was auch immer. Zahlt dafür einen monatlichen Beitrag und wir berichten davon. Aber das Berichten ist, sie zeigen Spiele, sie sagen nicht, das alles läuft dort falsch, weil sie wollen ja ihr Produkt auch nicht irgendwie schlecht reden. Das ist so die eine Ebene. Und ich glaube, was diese ganze Bedeutung von Fans für den Fußball betrifft, ich kann mir vorstellen, dass durch diese Corona-Krise das auch ein bisschen deutlicher wieder wird, weil es war ja jetzt eine Zeit lang, gab es ja ein paar Spiele ohne Zuschauern und ich glaube, dass man an denen, also jeder, der sich das angetan hat, hat gesehen, dass das so nicht funktioniert. Also dass das so ja auch niemand sehen will. Und ich bin gespannt, wie sich das Verhältnis nach Corona, also ich glaube, das ist eine Frage, die man auch irgendwie noch schwer beantworten kann, aber dass sich da auch was tun wird.
Ja, das kann gut sein. Ich habe so ein bisschen die Sorge, dass man sagen wird, Geisterspiele, das wollen wir nicht. Das kann niemand wollen, außer jemand ist so großer Nerd, dass er auch hören möchte, was die Spiele auf dem Spielfeld sagen. Dann sind Geisterspiele ganz toll. Ansonsten ist es einfach nicht anzuschauen. Man merkt auch, wie man selber das auf einmal emotionslos verfolgt, wenn da so ein Spiel läuft. Aber das ist vielleicht die Schlussfolgerung daraus nicht. Das ist, was wir jetzt vielleicht sagen würden, nämlich man braucht die Kurven, man braucht Stehplätze, man braucht dieses oft grenzüberschreitende, auch im Negativen manchmal grenzüberschreitend, aber eben auch im Positiven. Sondern dass man einfach nur da hinkommt und sagt, wir brauchen einfach Zuschauer im Stadion, aber die müssen eben nicht aus dieser organisierten Fanszene kommen, mit der man so viele Probleme hat.
Das kann natürlich alles passieren. Ich glaube trotz allem, dass selbst die, die dann eigentlich die Sitze auffüllen müssten, was vermissen würden. Also ich bin tatsächlich in den letzten Jahren auch eher kulturpessimistisch geworden, was so die weitere Entwicklung angeht und ich glaube auch, dass wir nach wie vor eine Fan-Kultur unter Druck erleben gerade. Und ich glaube, dass wir wahrscheinlich in zehn Jahren noch weniger Stimmung in den Städien haben werden. Aber trotz allem glaube ich, und das ist natürlich auch schon den Beharrungskräften der Ultrakurven oder der Fan-Kurven insgesamt zu verdanken, dass es das überhaupt noch gibt. Also das darf man eben auch nicht unterschätzen. Also wenn es nicht ab 97, 98 diesen ständigen Widerstand der Kurven gegeben hätte, hätten wir wahrscheinlich auch längst Sitzplätze und noch mehr Fahnenpässe und noch mehr Kameras, die auf die Fan-Kurven gerichtet sind.
Und welche Rolle spielt dann, weil du das jetzt gerade gesagt hast, würde mich für den Ballester dann aber auch interessieren, welche Rolle spielt da dann Freunde? Jetzt vielleicht auch mal, wenn wir in die Anfangszeit zurückgehen. Ich glaube, das hat sich ja auch ein bisschen gewandelt. Das berühmte Plakat in Rostock, was war es? Fußball lieben statt studieren, Freunde boykottieren. Das war ja glaube ich aus dem Jahr 2008 oder so. Ich glaube, das war, als ich bei euch Praktikum gemacht habe.
Genau, ein geflügeltes Wort, ein geflügeltes Wort auch für uns in der Redaktion. Jedes Mal, wenn es bei uns zu studiert wird, wird das gerne mal zitiert. Das war natürlich eine Reaktion auf einen Artikel, den ich geschrieben hatte, in dem ich diverse Auswüchse der Ultrakultur kritisiert habe. Das wurde damals tatsächlich so ein bisschen als Hochverrat angesehen in manchen Kurven. Ich würde sicherlich manche Sachen, die ich dort sehr harsh formuliert habe und auch sehr polemisch, heute glaube ich nicht mehr so sehen, weil sich meine Perspektive da etwas geweiht hat. Ich würde aber mal auch behaupten, dass das für die Ultrakurven mindestens genauso gilt. Ich glaube, dass wir heute ein respektvolles Verhältnis zu den Ultras haben. Ich glaube aber, dass tatsächlich hoffentlich sich unser Blick ein bisschen darüber hinaus weitet, denn im Ende sind wir keine Ultra-Versteher oder Fan-Kurven-Versteher, sondern uns ist daran gelegen, dass das, was man so Fußball- und Fan-Kultur nennen möchte, in den Stadien erhalten bleibt. Wir halten das tatsächlich für eine wahnsinnig lebendige Kultur, eine wichtige Kultur. Ich glaube, dass in der Vergangenheit und in der Gegenwart und hoffentlich auch in der Zukunft Fan-Kurven immer noch mal ein Platz sind, an dem sich Menschen ausprobieren können, an dem sie ihrer Kreativität freien Lauf lassen können, in dem sie, gerade wenn sie jugendlich sind, auch wirklich Grenzen austesten können. Ich glaube, dass das eine ganz wichtige Funktion des Fußballs ist und ich glaube auch, dass dem Fußball durch die Kurven wirklich was geschenkt wird an Lebendigkeit, an Kreativität, an Humor auch oft. Und man würde sich wünschen, dass die Clubs, die Funktionäre, auch die Geldgeber, auch die Leute in den Liga-Verbänden das begreifen, was das für ein wertvoller Schatz ist, der ihnen da gegeben wird, weil das tatsächlich, soweit ich das sehen kann, was die Kreativität und den Humor und die Intelligenz angeht, eigentlich fast einzigartig ist in Deutschland. Und es geht uns vielleicht noch so, um den zweiten Aspekt zu nennen, eben auch noch mal darum, dass nicht etwas rückabgewickelt wird, was ja erst so in den 60ern, 70ern begonnen hat, nämlich diese Aneignung, dieses Selbstbewusstsein der Anhänger, nicht nur Zuschauer zu sein, sondern Akteur des Spiels. Weil das ist ja so für mich Kern der Fußballkultur zu sagen, ich bin kein Zuschauer, ich bin niemand, der ein Ticket kauft und dann einfach unterhalten werden will, sondern ich bin Akteur des Spiels und Volker Goll aus Offenbach, der das Erwin mit herausgibt und inzwischen ja auch als Fanbetreuer, als Fansozialarbeiter arbeitet. Der hat mal gesagt, warum er eigentlich in Offenbach ins Stadion geht, dann war die Antwort, weil ich das Gefühl habe, dass es wichtig ist, dass ich da bin und dass ich gebraucht werde und das ist glaube ich das Wichtigste, dass die Leute ins Stadion gehen und nicht das Gefühl haben, es ist nur wichtig, dass ich mein Ticket bezahlt habe und ansonsten kann ich auch wegbleiben, sondern dass es einen Unterschied macht, ob ich da bin, ob ich oder ob ich eben nicht da bin und dass es entscheidend ist für den Sieg oder zumindest für einen Unentschieden, dass ich da bin und brülle und anfeuere. Und ich glaube, diese Kultur zu verteidigen und zu sagen, das ist wichtig, das ist wichtig für die Gesellschaft, das ist wichtig für die Clubs und das ist wichtig für den Fußball, das ist so, glaube ich, das, was Elf-Freunde sich auf die Fahne geschrieben hat und was, glaube ich, auch jeder tun sollte, der sich so für Fußballkultur interessiert und dem Fußballkultur am Herzen liegt.
Ich vermute, es deckt es sich dann auch mit dem Anspruch des Ballesterers, Jakob.
Also ich glaube, es ist ganz wesentlich, dass Fußball ein Zuschauersport ist und ich finde, Zuschauer jetzt auch gar nicht negativ konnotiert, sondern dass es ein Sport ist für die Fans, der von den Fans auch maßgeblich lebt und vor allem auch von den Fans vor Ort. Und eben, wie vorher schon gesagt, ich glaube, es ist ein Spiel ohne Zuschauer nicht anzuschauen. Ich glaube, es ist ganz wesentlich, dass die Fan-Kurven erhalten bleiben. Ich glaube auch, dass das ja auch mittlerweile sehr viele Clubs auch verstanden haben. Viele können zwar nicht wirklich gut damit umgehen, aber ich glaube, dass es viele verstanden haben, dass sie die Fans brauchen. Und ich würde sagen, spätestens, wenn Clubs in finanzielle Schwierigkeiten kommen, merken sie auch, was sie an den Fans haben, die sie ja dann oft diejenigen sind, die sie dann doch irgendwie retten oder neu übernehmen oder sonst irgendwas machen. Also wo dann die Aneignung, wie es der Philipp genannt hat, dann auch dann in eine formale Übernahme manchmal, in einer formalen Übernahme quasi manchmal gipfelt. Und ich glaube, dass die Popularität des Fußballs sehr, sehr stark von dem lebt, dass das ein Fansport ist. Und ja, also weil das vorgekommen ist, also ich würde sagen, uns wird der Vorwurf, dass wir zu weit weg von den Kurven sind, wird uns manchmal gemacht. Öfter hören wir den Vorwurf, dass wir zu nah dran sind. Ich glaube, dass das auch – also ich finde es auch gut, dass es beide Vorwürfe gibt, also so generell. Also ich finde, das ist – das sieht man auch irgendwie, wo man irgendwie steht. Aber ich glaube auch – ich glaube, das ist das, was – oder da komme ich eigentlich auch zu einer Antwort von vorher wieder zurück. Ich glaube, dass das, was uns unterscheidet jetzt am österreichischen Markt von den anderen Medien, ist, dass wir Fans einfach ernst nehmen und dass wir auf sie zugehen, dass wir uns anhören, was sie zu sagen haben. Das heißt, dass wir eigentlich unsere journalistische Arbeit machen. Das heißt, das ist ja auch etwas, was wir in anderen Bereichen auch machen sollten. Also man redet mit verschiedenen Teilen einer Geschichte. Das ist so quasi das, was man wahrscheinlich irgendwie so – ich bin ja kein studierter Journalist, aber – mir denkt, das ist eine der ersten Sachen, die man lernt, ist zu sagen, okay, hol dir Stellungnahmen von verschiedenen Stellen quasi ein und ich glaube, dass das gerade auch bei dem Fan-Thema extrem wichtig ist und ich glaube, dass man sich leider viel zu stark daran gewöhnt hat, dass das oft nicht der Fall ist.
Aber gleichzeitig ist es ja so, dass jetzt gerade der Ballesterer in großen wirtschaftlichen Problemen ist und bei Freunde sah ja auch nicht mal alles rosig aus, das haben wir ja unter anderem im Intro auch gehört. Kann es nicht vielleicht auch sein, dass wir drei – ich würde mich da ausdrücklich mit dazu zählen – so ein bisschen einem veralteten Fußballkulturbegriff nachtrauern, der aber vielleicht gar nicht mehr so wirklich durch die Realität der Fußballfans gedeckt wird, weil sonst müsste es ja euch, Jakob, eigentlich auch besser gehen. Weil dem kann man ja nicht widersprechen, dass ihr die Fanperspektive darstellt und dass ihr den extra Kilometer geht, den ganz viele Medien nicht gehen wollen, wenn es um Themen rund um den Fußball geht.
Ja, also ich würde sagen, in irgendeiner Weise, den Vorwurf quasi veraltet zu sein, kann man glaube ich sogar auch ein bisschen teilen oder könnte ich auch nachvollziehen. Also ich glaube, wir sind jetzt nicht das oder wir sind auch älter geworden. Es ist wahrscheinlich das, was in einem Ballestra steht, vielleicht von der Lebensrealität eines 15- oder 20-jährigen Ultras. Vielleicht gibt es da auch ganz sicher Unterschiede. Und es gibt da auch ganz sicher Medien oder neue Arten, wie man sich über Fußball, über all das, was einen interessiert, informiert. Sonst glaube ich nicht, dass das automatisch heißt, dass wir gescheitert sind, weil ich nicht glaube, dass der Markt allein alles regelt. Weil man nicht sagen kann, ok, nur weil wir nicht genug Anzeigen verkaufen oder weil wir nicht genug Avos verkaufen oder wie auch immer, heißt das, dass das, was wir machen, irrelevant ist. Da muss man sich anschauen, in welchem Umfeld Medien agieren, in welchem Umfeld auch Printmedien agieren. Das ist gerade sehr schwierig, würde ich sagen. Es kann sein, dass sich das durch unsere Modelle, wie sie bisher bestanden sind, dass sich das dann vielleicht nicht ausgeht. Aber ich glaube, da ja jetzt auch die Kampagne quasi, oder die Rettungskampagne ist ja da auch in die Richtung ein bisschen ein Versuch zu sagen, ok, wie wir kalkuliert haben, was der Markt machen kann, so sehen wir, es ist ein bisschen schwierig. Vielleicht brauchen wir da auch noch eine andere Art der Unterstützung. Und wenn diese Kampagne jetzt funktioniert, würde ich sagen, könnte man sagen, ok, es gibt sehr stark das Signal, dass man sowas wie uns braucht und dass man die Art, wie wir berichten, auch braucht und dass es dafür auch genug Leute gibt, die bereit sind, Geld zu zahlen, auch wenn das vielleicht mehr ist als die 5, 90 Euro, die ein Ballesterer normal im Handel kostet.
Wahrscheinlich hat man auch mehr Loyalität dann von denjenigen, die einen gefunden haben, weil sie ja – also das sind ja diejenigen, die dann auch erkennen, das, was ich hier lesen kann, in Elf Freunde im Ballesterer, das bekomme ich so in dieser Art nirgendwo sonst und deswegen ist man dann besonders loyal. Ich glaube, bei euch, Philipp, sind ja auch die Abonnenten und Abonnentinnen schon immer eine wichtige Säule gewesen für den Erfolg von Elf Freunde.
Ja, also ich kann so sagen, wenn es nicht die Abonnenten gegeben hätte, gäbe es Elf Freunde auch schon seit 2002 nicht mehr. Also wir haben ja am Anfang auch Illusionen gehabt, was so Anzeigenvermarktung anging. Da haben wir gedacht, das reicht, wenn wir da einfach mal anrufen und dann sagen alle, hey, das neue frische Fußballmagazin, da schalte ich mal unbedingt eine Anzeige. Das war natürlich nicht so. Und auch jetzt ist es tatsächlich so, dass unsere Abonnenten eigentlich die auch sind, die für uns auch tatsächlich irgendwie das entscheidende Kriterium sind. Also es ist gut, wenn man sie hat, weil sie natürlich einem auch eine Unabhängigkeit gegenüber Schwankungen im Anzeigenbereich geben. Wir haben tatsächlich auch, wir gehören ja seit 2010 teilweise zu Grün und Jahr und zum großen Konzert, haben tatsächlich dort im Verlag auch die wirklich mit deutlichem Abstand höchste Verweildauer von Abonnenten. Also Elf-Freunde-Abonnenten bleiben das auf 10 oder 11 Jahre. Das ist sehr viel länger als bei anderen Magazinen. Deswegen bin ich sehr froh, dass das so ist. Und ich glaube auch, dass das sowohl beim Ballestra als auch bei Elf-Freunde gar nicht anders geht, dass man Leute hat, die wirklich sagen, ich brauche diese Art von Fußballöffentlichkeit und ich brauche diese ganz spezielle Form von Fußballberichterstattung. Denn das ist, glaube ich, so eine Krux, die man sehr häufig ein bisschen unterschätzt. Man ist zwar in einem Massenmarkt tätig, bei Ballestra und wir auch, wo man immer denkt, da muss es doch unfassbar viele Leute geben, die das spannend finden, die was über Fußball lesen wollen. Aber gleichzeitig sind wir durch unsere Ansprache, durch unser spezielles Thema, nämlich Fankultur, Fußballkultur im weitesten Sinne, sind wir natürlich trotz allem auch Nischenmagazine. Wir bedienen den ganz klassischen Fußball-Mainstream dann eben auch nicht. Das macht es manchmal ein bisschen knifflig, glaube ich.
Ja, und wir sind Monatsmagazine auch noch. Das macht es auch nochmal schwieriger, ständig präsent zu sein. Man kann sich auch, wenn man Fußball interessiert ist, stelle ich es mir auch schwierig vor, wenn man das ausschließlich über den Ballestra oder die 11 Freunde macht. Soll es auch geben, oder hoffe ich auch, dass es das auch gibt, aber im Prinzip, du brauchst ja auch mehrere Dinge.
Welche Rolle haben denn dann für euch die Fußballturniere im eigenen Land gespielt? Also Jakob, bei euch die EM in Schweiz und Österreich 2008. War das auch so ein wichtiger Punkt? Da warst du ja dann auch schon fest involviert, um eben im Massenmarkt bekannter zu werden und dann die paar Nischenleute sich rauszuziehen, die dann am Ballesterer hängen bleiben?
Ja, ich muss sagen, da war ich relativ neu dabei, also irgendwie seit zwei Jahren. Ich weiß, dass das Jahr 2008 für uns extrem wichtig war, weil wir extrem große Hoffnungen gehabt haben, dass jetzt der Durchbruch endlich funktioniert und dass wir endlich neue Anzeigenkunden ansprechen, dass wir viel mehr Abos verkaufen und dass wir viel mehr Einzelhefte verkaufen. Wir haben auch 2008 unsere Erscheinungsweise umgestellt. Seit 2008 kommen wir zehnmal im Jahr raus. Das heißt, wir haben da schon von der EM oder von der Stimmung, die da war, sicher profitiert. Aber ich glaube, der Philipp kann das dann für Deutschland und WM 2006 besser zählen. Ich glaube, dass das bei uns nicht in dem Ausmaß erfolgreich war wie bei den L-Freunden. Prinzipiell ist es immer schwierig zu sagen, was gewesen wäre, hätte es die EM nicht gegeben. Klar ist, dass wir dort leider auch Fehler gemacht haben oder Fehleinschätzungen gemacht haben. Wir haben zum Beispiel zur EM-Ausgabe 2008 eine CD beigelegt, die wir selbst produziert haben, mit einem Label gemeinsam. War wahnsinnig teuer und wir haben uns gedacht, ok, das wird jetzt was ändern. Hat natürlich nichts gebracht, außer dass wir sehr hohe Ausgaben hatten.
Was war denn auf der CD drauf?
Ja, da waren so Musiker aus der Indie-Szene, die irgendwelche Fußballlieder gespielt haben.
Starker Pitch schon mal.
Ein paar waren ganz gut, auch gar nicht so unbekannte Leute. Ein paar waren ganz gut, aber trotzdem wollten wir vielleicht entweder über die EM informieren.
Jakob, du klingst schon so wahnsinnig angewidert.
Nein, diese Entscheidung, diese CD zu produzieren, da kann ich die Schuld von mir weisen, war, glaube ich, eine der größten Fehlentscheidungen.
Ich habe unglaublich Lust, diese CD zu hören.
Ja, ich auch.
Das ist total schade, dass ich damals den Ballesterer… Ich habe euch genau dann kennengelernt. Also, 2008 hatte ich ja mein Praktikum bei Freunde, und da bin ich dann so eingetaucht und habe dann auch den Ballesterer abonniert gehabt. Menschen, da habe ich die CD verpasst. Das muss ja Wahnsinn sein.
Nein, aber wir haben sie noch und ist ja eine tolle CD, ein tolles Projekt, hätte alles super funktionieren können. Ich versuche mich zu retten.
Bei eBay gehen auf jeden Fall gerade die Preise in die Höhe.
Das sage ich dir jetzt halt. Ja, genau. Vielleicht finden wir noch eine Schachtel und versteigen uns dann auch im Sinne unserer Kampagne. 2008 war es auch erstmals möglich, eine professionelle Stelle zu haben. Das war aber die einzige. Sonst war das Magazin nach wie vor ehrenamtlich zum größten Teil. Das hat sich langsam, also ich würde sagen bei uns alles, immer sehr langsam in sehr kleinen Schritten entwickelt. Und so diesen Boost von einem Turnier hat es leider nicht gegeben.
Das war tatsächlich bei uns ein bisschen anders. Also diese WM 2006 war tatsächlich so ein bisschen so ein Brandbeschleuniger bei uns, weil es tatsächlich glaube ich fast beispiellos war, wie sich plötzlich unfassbar riesige gesellschaftliche Kreise für Fußball interessiert haben. Also das war sicherlich vorher ein etwas wiederer Volkssport. Dann gab es natürlich schon Professionalisierung, Kommerzialisierung, all diesen Fußballboom. Aber das hat tatsächlich dann rund um 2004, 2005 nochmal tatsächlich unvorstellbare Ausmaße in Deutschland bekommen. Da war die Euphorie tatsächlich ein bisschen anders auch noch als 2008 in Österreich, weil man auch nicht vergessen gab, vorher gab es diese tristen Jahre, diese schlimmen Europameisterschaften 2000, 2004, das ganze Land gierte irgendwie nach Erfolg und nach dieser WM und da war es dann eben plötzlich so, dass auch viele Medien, viele Leute, die irgendwas mit Fußball machen wollten, so eine Abspielfläche suchten. Und ich glaube, ich habe das nie wieder danach erlebt, dass wirklich noch jeder, der auch vorher nichts mit Fußball zu tun hatte, plötzlich über Poldi und Schweini und Klinsi und dieses ganze Nationalmannschaftsprojekt informiert war. Also, das hat in Deutschland schon was ausgelöst. Und ich würde gar nicht sagen, dass wir jetzt von diesen ganzen Fan-Meilen-Leuten profitiert haben, sondern eher davon, dass es auch ganz, ganz viele Leute gab, die ganz froh waren inmitten dieser ganzen, wie ist das immer, positiver Patriotismus, Euphorie, die Schlandisierung und die schlimmen Gesichtsfarben, Schwarz-Rot-Gold und das Gebrüll und das Krakele und das Fahnen aus dem Fenster hängen. Dass es da auch noch eine Stimme gab, die versucht hat, das alles irgendwie einzuordnen. Deswegen, glaube ich, hat das bei uns funktioniert. Das konnte man dann in den Abo-Zahlen sehen, das konnte man bei den Verkäufen sehen. Ich glaube, wir haben 2004 noch ungefähr 20.000 Hefte verkauft und dann waren es um 2006 plötzlich 35.000 oder 40.000 und das hat man richtig spürbar gemerkt. Du konntest dann in jeden Kiosk gehen und überall gab es 11 Freunde und solche Sachen haben dann einfach auf eine andere Art und Weise funktioniert als vorher. Insofern war das für uns schon wichtig. Das hat schon echt gut funktioniert. Ohne CD.
Sehr schade, was ich sehr bedauere.
Ja, es ist traurig.
Aber ganz interessante Connection zwischen Musik und auch Indie-Musik und Fußballmagazinen, die wir da haben. Also 11 Freunde, ganz lange ja vom Intro-Verlag dann herausgegeben und jetzt höre ich vom Ballesterer solche Jugend-Sünden aus dem Jahr 2008. Da könnte man mal noch übernachten.
Ich habe ein ganz schlechtes Gewissen. Nein, ich glaube, dass es auch kein Zufall ist. Weil es ja aus einer ähnlichen Subkultur kommt, diese Fans in Bewegung und irgendeine Musik interessiert. Bevor wir im nationalen Vertrieb waren, sind wir in Plattenläden aufgelegt worden. Das war auch der Ort, wo wir gehen gelernt haben. Eine total wichtige Verbindung. Einer unserer frühen Schwerpunktthemen war auch Fußball und Musik.
Bei Freunde gab es ja die Verbindung über den Intro-Verlag auch schon. Vielleicht ist das ja auch so ein bisschen sinnbildlich, Philipp. Du konntest schon immer mit Thies Ullmann über Fußball sprechen, aber nicht unbedingt mit Helene Fischer. Aber seitdem sie im Pokal-Endspiel mal singen durfte, wahrscheinlich auch mit ihr.
Nein, um Gottes Willen. Man muss tatsächlich auch so, glaube ich, als Elffreunde und auch als Ballester und glaube ich, als jedes Magazin, das sich da tummelt, schauen, dass man den allzu klebrigsten Mainstream dann doch umschifft. Also ich glaube, jedes Magazin, das sich da tummelt, jedes Magazin, das über Profenfußball berichtet, muss, glaube ich, viel aushalten an Zumutungen, die es gibt. Das finde ich nicht nur für Magazine, sondern auch für Anhänger. Du kannst ja so ein hundertprozentiger und authentischer Fußballafficionado sein. Wenn du ins Fußballstadion hineingehst, wirst du trotzdem ganz, ganz viele Dinge erleben, gegen die du nichts machen kannst. Also krakeelende Stadionsprecher, diese viertelichen Durchsagen nach Toren, die Werbeblöcke. Na ja, also letztlich ist diese Frage, inwiefern du Staffage bist für eine Verwertung dieses Sports, das ist eine Sache, mit der sich natürlich auch Kurven auseinandersetzen müssen. Jede Farbe, prächtige Choreografie ist der klassische Opener für eine Sky-Reportage und führt auch zum Verkaufen. Also insofern ist Profifußball immer etwas, was erstmal auch Schmerzen auslöst und erstmal sagt, diese ganze klebrige Inszenierung, dieser ganze Pathos, diese falschen Gefühle, die da natürlich auch irgendwie präsentiert werden. Wie schaffe ich eigentlich diesen ganzen Schrott und dieses ganze Geldgierige und dieses ganze, ich hänge allem noch ein Preisschild um und irgendwann müssen sogar die Einlaufkinder noch was dafür bezahlen, dass sie irgendwie mit aufs Spielfeld dürfen. Wie trenne ich das von dem, was authentisch ist? Und eigentlich ist das tatsächlich die Herausforderung, die man dann immer wieder hat und jeden Monat und eigentlich, wenn man das Internet dann zunimmt, jeden Tag aufs Neue hat.
Das stimmt natürlich. Ich meinte es eher so, dass man daran ablesen kann, wie einfach der Fußball in der Gesellschaft angekommen ist, dass eben jetzt Helene Fischer mit Fußball-Nationalspielern in Instagram-Stories auftaucht und das war ja unbedingt vor 20 Jahren jetzt nur nicht so. Also es gab schon immer musikalische Verbrechen im Umfeld des Fußballs. Ich meine nicht euch, Jakob.
Nein, aber damals gab es ja noch den Orgel-Spieler, der immer 78 mit ins Quartier gefahren ist. Also wenn man sich nur die Platten anguckt der Nationalmannschaft, also Udo Jürgens, Michael Schantze, Peter Alexander, dann merkt man eher, das war eher so biederes Schlager-Genre. Und natürlich ist das inzwischen so, wenn Noel Geleger und Liam Geleger sich bei City da auf der Tribüne herumtreiben, jeder englische Punk-Musiker irgendwie seinen eigenen Verein hat. Und dass da hierzulande tatsächlich auch so ist, ob es nun TS. Uhlmann mit St. Pauli ist oder Materia mit Hansa Rostock, da merkt man natürlich schon, dass wenn es auch für Indie-Künstler akzeptabel ist, zum Fußball zu gehen, dann muss sich ja wirklich was verändert haben.
Wenn ich jetzt damals bei euch in die Redaktion gekommen wäre, Philipp, lass mal bei der ersten Anfang noch, also das wäre dann quasi die Redaktion wäre die private Wohnung von Reynaldo gewesen. Was hätte ich dort vorgefunden? Du musst nicht so sehr ins Detail gehen jetzt um die privaten Details, aber was die Freunde betrifft.
Na ja, also tatsächlich war es so, dass wir ja keinen Redaktionsraum hatten, sondern dass das Wohnzimmer von Reynaldo in Friedrichshain dann wirklich unser Redaktionsraum war. Da hockte dann Reynaldo an seinem Rechner und immer mal wieder klingelte sein Privatanschluss und Abonnenten waren dran, die dann eine Adresse durchgeben wollten. Und da waren wir sehr, sehr froh, dass wir dann tatsächlich aus diesem Wohnzimmer dann nach einem Jahr in unsere ersten Redaktionsräume umgezogen sind. Da waren wir mit so einer Aktionskünstlerin Frau Karrenberg zusammen, die immer sauer war, weil wir unser benutztes Geschirr immer in die Badewanne geworfen haben. Also ich sag mal so, ich glaube, das ist ja überall so. Wenn man so was Neues gründet und seine tausend Abonnenten und seine tausend Leute hat, die das am Kiosk kaufen, dann hat man immer prekäre Verhältnisse, was so Redaktionsräume angeht. Also es war keine Garage, aber es war auch nicht das, was ich glamouröse Redaktionsräume nennen würde.
Und wie viele Artikel in den ersten Elf-Freunde-Ausgaben kamen von dir unter zum Teil haarsträubenden Synonymen? Also ich habe bis zu zehn, glaube ich, fast alle Elf-Freunde hier bei mir stehen. Also entweder sind wir sehr internationale Schreiberlinge oder du warst irgendwann zu faul, dir Pseudonyme auszudenken.
Ja, ich habe tatsächlich irgendwann tatsächlich einfach nur noch im Telefonbuch geschaut und wahllos an Nachnamen gereiht. Also es war natürlich auch so, dass ganz, ganz viele Leute, von denen wir dachten, die schaffen es auf jeden Fall intelligent über Fußball zu schreiben, dass die gesagt haben, ja gerne, aber nur mit Honorar. Und das war tatsächlich für uns gar nicht machbar. Und wir fanden es jetzt auch öde, wenn dann unter allen Fotos Renaldo Kudu und unter allen Texten Philipp Köster steht. Insofern haben wir dann ein bisschen angefangen, dann auch uns noch Pseudonyme zuzulegen, teilweise auch mit, also Renaldo mit seinen Fotos. Das hat Gott sei Dank irgendwann aufgehört, weil wir tatsächlich ganz viele Leute so aus unserer Fansin-Bekannschaft noch herangezogen haben, die es gewohnt waren, ausgebeutet zu werden. Aber vorher war das ganz schön anstrengend. Also gerade die ersten Ausgaben, die inzwischen ja auch bei Ebay durchaus hoch gehandelt werden, da stehen teilweise Sachen drin, von denen ich mich noch erinnere, dass ich kurz vor Tore Schluss noch zusammengeknüppelt habe. Das ist heute auch nicht mehr so richtig gut lesbar. Manches Frühwerk tut da noch echt weh, beim heute Lesen.
Na gut, das geht ja jedem so, der mal etwas erschaffen hat und Jahre später draufguckt.
Die erste Rasenfunk-Sendung, kannst du dir die heute noch anhören?
Nein, auf gar keinen Fall. Das ist alles fürchterlich. Also wirklich alles von vorne bis hinten unerträglich. Ich möchte jedem davon abraten. Habe ich es noch abrufbar. Es ist noch abrufbar.
Bringt er vielleicht mal als CD raus, habe ich mir überlegt.
Bei der nächsten EM vielleicht.
Ja, das ist 2024. Das wird dann der Sargnagel auch für 11 Freunde.
Und Rasenfunk kannst du dann auch zumachen.
Ja, Rasenfunk, ob es den dann auch gibt. Jakob, wie war es denn bei dir? Als du das erste Mal in der Ballestere-Redaktion war, wann war das dann? 2006, 2005, so um den Dreh rum?
Ja, genau, das war 2006. Also genau, das erste Treffen im Ballestere war auch gar nicht mehr in der Redaktion, sondern das war im Kaffeehaus. Ist ja ein Wiener Magazin. Also da habe ich einfach, ich habe quasi gesehen, dass der Ballester einen Marathonerschwerpunkt plant und ich bin gerade aus Neapel zurück und habe mir gedacht, vielleicht kann ich dir etwas beisteuern und habe halt irgendwie dem Chefredakteur quasi ein Mail geschrieben und gefragt und er hat gemeint, ja, treffen wir uns mal im Kaffee und so ist das entstanden. Damals haben wir doch sehr langfristig gedacht, also diese Ankündigung war irgendwie, glaube ich, ein Dreivierteljahr oder ein Jahr fast, bevor da der Schwerpunkt hätte stattfinden sollen. Dazwischen war die WM 2006 und dort, da gab es so ein, also ich sage jetzt nicht Public Viewing dazu, weil das wird dem nicht entsprechen, sondern es gab halt ein Lokal, wo die Valestra-Leute gemeinsam die Spiele geschaut haben. Und dort bin ich dann vorbeigekommen, also das heißt, die ersten Treffen waren alle irgendwie mit Lokalen verbunden und habe halt dann mit dem Reinhardt geplaudert und irgendwie, damals war halt Cacciopoli der Skandal und ich habe halt irgendwie dadurch, dass ich gerade in Italien meine Kontakte dort auch gehabt habe, zumindest italienisch können und habe halt auch angeboten, was zu schreiben zu einem Nebenaspekt und so bin ich dann schon vor der Marathoner-Ausgabe quasi reingerutscht. Und dann die ersten Treffen, da muss ich sagen, das damalige Redaktionsbüro war großartig. Das haben wir gemeinsam mit einer Literaturzeitschrift Zentrale Lage, Innenstadt, war toll. Da mussten wir dann leider irgendwann raus. Jetzt sind wir immer noch relativ zentral, hatten am Anfang auch noch eine Kooperation mit der Literaturzeitschrift, sind mittlerweile aber quasi in einer Erdgeschosswohnung, in einer umgebauten allein. Und da würde ich sagen, ich weiß nicht, wann waren wir euch besuchen, Philipp, in Berlin 2014?
Ich glaube 2013, wenn es um dieses Treffen der Fußballmagazinmacher aus ganz Europa geht.
Genau, dann 2013, da waren wir schwer beeindruckt, wie euer Büro dort ausgeschaut hat. Also das ist nicht vergleichbar. Bei uns ist es quasi ein großer Raum, viel Badewanne gibt es auch als Lager und so weiter.
Also kein Kaffegeschirr in der Badewanne, sondern Balesterer-Ausgaben?
Ja, Balesterer oder irgendwelche alten Stühle, die wir irgendwie nicht mehr verwenden oder alles Mögliche.
Okay, ich frage nicht weit. Ja, Philipp, bei euch hat sich das ja schnell professionalisiert. Also aus der Privatwohnung heraus ging es dann in die Wohnung mit der Künstlerin und dann später an den Prenzlauer Berg, da war dann auch ich, mal kurz für drei Monate, glaube ich, im Jahr 2008. Da kann ich mich jetzt noch daran erinnern. Und ich hatte damals, als Praktikant hat man ja die Aufgabe, unter anderem die Tür zu öffnen, wenn geklingelt wird. Im meisten Fall war es der Postbote und man musste irgendwie eins von 200 Paketen entgegennehmen und an der Wand stapeln. Es waren aber hin und wieder auch Leute aus der Fußballszene. Ich erinnere mich da noch an eine sehr lustige Begegnung mit Andreas Rettig, an die er keine Erinnerung mehr hat. Ich habe ihn mal danach gefragt. Möchte er aber deswegen jetzt auch nicht hier in den Podcast ziehen. Wie war denn aber so der Eindruck, den ihr hinterlassen habt bei Leuten aus dem Fußballgeschäft? Wie lang hat es denn gedauert, bis ihr da ernst genommen wurdet?
Also am Anfang war es tatsächlich so, dass einem offene Ignoranz begegnet ist. Da wird immer gerne der Hertha-Pressesprecher von damals zitiert, dessen Name ich jetzt nicht nennen würde, sonst könnte man Hansi Fälser zu leicht erkennen. Nämlich der dann sagte, kommt doch wieder, wenn ihr 100.000 Auflage habt und vorher brauchte gar nicht bei uns anzuklingeln. Andere haben uns einfach weggedrückt, wenn wir da angerufen haben. Und ich glaube, das ging so nach und nach einfach immer weiter, so dass Spieler, die bei uns dann zum Interview waren, auch in der Lage waren, das weiter zu erzählen, dass es ganz angenehm war, dass man schöne Fotos gemacht hat. Also es ist ja bis heute so, dass eigentlich unser Anspruch ist, dass wir wirklich jeden unserer Artikel mit eigenen Bildern bebildern, also dass wir keine Stockfotos, keine Agenturen benutzen, möglichst wenig, wenn es nicht gerade historische Ereignisse sind. Also das haben Spieler, Trainer, Funktionäre auch zu schätzen gewusst, dass sie bei uns länger reden können als normal und dass nicht jeder Satz so verkürzt wird, dass eine Schlagzeile draus wird. Es gibt natürlich so ein paar Leute, die dann tatsächlich so Freunde des Hauses geworden sind. Also Andi Rettig gehört tatsächlich dazu, Thomas Hitzelsberger ist so jemand, aber vor allen Dingen Ewald Lin, der seinen Sohn bei uns als Praktikanten hatte und irgendwann einfach bei uns vor der Tür stand und dann sah, dass bei uns ein Schreibtisch frei war und sich dann einfach hingesetzt hat. Er blieb dann einfach zwei Wochen bei uns, Ewald, und hat an einem Rechner von uns bei Transfermarkt.de seinen Kader für Panionios Athen zusammengestellt. Da werde ich nie vergessen, wie sein Sohn immer hinter ihm schon sagte, der ist gut, den muss er auch noch kaufen. Und Ewald telefonierte dann immer mit einem griechischen Gewährsmann in Athen, Georgios, und gab dann immer die Transfers durch. Und ich glaube, manch ein Praktikant bei uns hat echt einen Herzinfarkt gekriegt, wenn der dann morgens reinkam und dann sah es Ewald da schon und hat schon Spieler gesichtet. Also ich glaube, dass es aber trotz allem auch ganz gut ist, jetzt mal abseits der paar persönlichen Freundschaften, die wir natürlich so hatten, dass wir auch immer eine gewisse Distanz gewahrt haben. Also wenn man sich natürlich anguckt, dass ganz, ganz viel in diesem Business, sehr viel über diese Kumpellei läuft, da hat der eine Mann dem anderen Gefallen getan und dafür darf der dann wieder beim Doppelpass noch was erzählen und der hat da noch ein Geheimnis, das steckt da dem und also diese ganzen untereinander Gefälligkeiten, die es da so gibt, da hat sich Elf-Freunde tatsächlich immer weitgehend rausgehalten. Natürlich verstehen wir uns auch mit manchen aus dem Business besser als mit den anderen, aber ich glaube, dass insgesamt es eigentlich wenige Leute gibt, die uns in offener Feindschaft zugetan sind und andersrum aber auch wenige, mit denen wir uns ständig in die Arme fallen und sagen, ey, was seid ihr denn für Supertypen? Und ich glaube, dass das Elf-Freunde so, was die Distanz angeht, eigentlich ganz gut tut.
Jakob, wie hat sich denn die Akzeptanz vom Ballesterer über die Jahre hinweg verändert?
Ja, ich würde sagen, der Anfang ist ähnlich.
Evald Linen hat bei euch auch einen Kader zusammengestellt.
Ja, Evald Linen war dann drei Wochen bei uns. Wir haben am Anfang sehr stark kämpfen müssen, quasi um Akkreditierungen, um Interviews, um generell Umaufmerksamkeit, das hat sich langsam, aber stetig verbessert. Jetzt, am österreichischen Markt oder so, haben wir da eigentlich gar keine Probleme mehr. International kommt es darauf an. Bei sehr großen Clubs tun wir uns immer noch schwer, zu sagen, wenn wir einen Liverpool-Schwerpunkt planen, rechnen wir das Club-Interview nicht ein. Das wäre unrealistisch. Wir probieren es dann vielleicht, aber da sind wir natürlich zu klein. Das interessiert die ganz Großen nicht. Aber im Prinzip würde ich sagen, dass die Akzeptanz auf jeden Fall stark gestiegen ist. Ich glaube, diese Kumpellei, wie es Philipp genannt hat, gibt es bei uns den Fachbegriff Verhaberung. Das ist sicher etwas, wo man natürlich aufpassen muss und wo man schauen muss, dass man da nicht dabei ist. Das sind wir auch und da achten wir sehr genau drauf, weil ich glaube, gerade für ein Magazin wie unseres, das sich irgendwie auf die Fahnen heftet, wir schauen, dass wir kritisch sind, wir schauen, dass wir unabhängig sind, dann kann man nicht solche Nebendeals laufen lassen.
Aber woher kommt denn das, dass es im Fußball so verbreitet ist? Wenn man jetzt einfach mal den Journalismus als Ganzes betrachtet und sich dann den Sport- und den Fußball-Journalismus herauspickt, dann würde ich behaupten, dass es wenige andere Bereiche, vielleicht noch Motor – nee, nicht Motorsport, sondern Autosjournalismus, vielleicht noch Reisejournalismus, aber es gibt ganz wenige Bereiche, bei denen eben die Verschränkung zwischen Journalisten und Akteuren der Branche so eng ist wie beim Fußball. Und ich frage mich manchmal, woher das eigentlich kommt.
Also ich glaube, beim Skifahren ist es noch viel schlimmer. Oh ja, stimmt.
Das ist die österreichische Perspektive.
Nein, aber da gibt es ja da nicht so diesen Spruch ab, weiß ich nicht, wie viele Meter gibt es, kein Sieh mehr und so weiter. Na, ich glaube aber tatsächlich, dass es diese Verhaberung oder diese Versuche der Verhaberung, dass es die in allen Bereichen gibt. Ich glaube, dass es im Sport vielleicht noch mal klarer wird oder dass es im Sport insofern leichter wird, weil man irgendwie dieses Thema hat und wo man ja auch alle, sind ja alle für einen Sport und das wollen ja alle guten Fußball sehen und was weiß ich was. Da versucht man schnell irgendwie so eine Vereinnahmung herzustellen. Aber ich glaube, dass es so Phänomene, dass irgendwie Pressesprecher oder auch Akteure aus Unternehmen, Politiker, was auch immer, dass die versuchen, die Paar Journalisten, die für sie zuständig sind, quasi einzukochen. Ich glaube, das gibt es ganz sicher überall und ist ein Problem, würde ich sagen, vor allem von Ressourcen des Journalismus. Und da gehen wir über den Sportjournalismus weit heraus. Also wenn man sagt, es gibt einfach zu wenig Stellen im Journalismus, um Dinge gut zu recherchieren, dann kriegt man halt schlecht recherchierte Pressemitteilungen, die man halt leicht ändert, aber wo auch nicht die Zeit ist, da mehr zu machen.
Das glaube ich auch. Und das ist natürlich auch vielleicht nicht ganz so kulturpessimistisch, wie du das formuliert hast, Max. Ich glaube, dass du viele Branchen hast, wo es ein wahnsinniges bussige Tour und, wie Jakob das so schön genannt hat, Verhaberung gibt. Nämlich dort, wo es darum geht, mit Gefälligkeiten und mit Informationen zu handeln. Wenn ich mir die Schlagerbranche angucke und anderes, da gibt es wahrscheinlich auch unfassbar viele Deals und Absprachen. Ich glaube aber, im Fußball ist es eben auch so, dass die eigentliche Nichtigkeit des Gegensteines, also Fußball ist ja entgegen unserer aller Art, das zu einer lebensentscheidenden Sache hochzuheben. Am Ende natürlich auch nur Sport und Entertainment und Unterhaltung und so weiter. Und die Frage ist, was für News gibt es denn da eigentlich, die gehandelt werden können? Und da befinden sich natürlich manche, also Pressesprecher, Trainer, Funktionäre, in der wunderbaren Situation, Günstlinge sich zu halten, denen man Informationen zusteckt, weil das so eine Ware ist, mit der man oder eine Währung auch mit der man so handeln kann. Insofern glaube ich, ist der Fußball mit seinen ganz vielen kleinen Tratschgeschichten, seinen Geheimnissen, seinen ganzen Abgründen ein bisschen prädestiniert, um gerade auch so eine ganz spezielle Art von Gefälligkeitsjournalismus dann auch zu provozieren. Und ich glaube, dass es viele Kollegen gibt, die sich dem entziehen. Also das passiert bei Spiegel Online und bei der SZ und bei der Zeit und anderswo sicherlich genauso. Aber es gibt auch viele, die nichts großartiger finden, als ihr Handy hochzurecken und Selfies mit den Stars zu machen und mit denen Deals auszuhandeln und mit denen sogenannte bunte Geschichten zu machen und Tratsch weiterzutreiben. Und ich glaube, dass das so zwei Aspekte von Sportjournalismus sind, die manchmal auch auf unangenehme Art und Weise aufeinanderprallen.
Und gleichzeitig entzieht ihr euch ja mit euren Magazinen allein schon durch die monatliche Erscheinungsweise so ein bisschen diesem Newszyklus, in dem man dann eben nicht mitmachen muss. Also Freunde, macht da mit, aber auf eine sehr verfluchte Art und Weise, in dem Covergeschichten kurz danach sind die entsprechenden Spieler verletzt oder entlassen oder wie auch immer.
Oder Jürgen Klinsmann ist zurück in den USA, ab dem wir noch verkündet haben, dass er jetzt mal richtig angreift, der Jürgen.
Wobei, das war ja schon wieder so passend zu dieser abstrusen Situation, dass es ja fast trotzdem ein Kaufanreiz war, dass wir sich gedacht haben, ok, da will ich jetzt nochmal eintauchen in diese Welt von vor einer Woche.
Das hat tatsächlich auch, obwohl es tatsächlich dann ein bisschen obsolet war, das Cover als Magazin oder als Verkauf echt sehr, sehr gut geklappt. Trotzdem war es ein bisschen nervig, weil man sich natürlich gewünscht hätte, dass dieser Klinsi-Wahnsinn noch mal ein paar Tage weitergeht.
Aber davon abgesehen halten sich monatliche Publikationen ein bisschen aus diesen üblichen Mechanismen. Ich muss jetzt exklusiv melden, was ich gehört habe, ein bisschen raus. Und auf der anderen Seite hat man aber eben das Problem, was ja vorhin Jakob auch schon angesprochen hat, dass man als monatlich erscheinendes Medium eben nicht so viel Grundaufmerksamkeit bekommt und eben weniger mögliche Kontaktpunkte hat zu Leserinnen und Lesern. Welches Problem ist jetzt größer? Das, dass man so wenig Aufmerksamkeit hat und damit dann vielleicht auch mit einem veränderten Mediennutzungsverhalten konfrontiert wird? Oder eben das, dass man sich auf andere Themen konzentrieren kann? Das ist kein Problem, das war jetzt falsch von mir anmoderiert, sondern ist eine Chance. Also wie würdet ihr diese Abwägungen jetzt in eurer aktuellen Lage für euch bewerten?
Für uns als Elf-Freunde war es ja eigentlich immer wichtig, tatsächlich so den Blick mal über reine Fan-Themen hinaus zu richten, aus zwei der Gründen. Also erstens glaube ich, dass das, was wir uns um das Jahr 2000 quasi so auf die Fahnen geschrieben hatten, im Jahr 2010, 2012 oder 2020 nicht mehr so entscheidend ist für den Anhänger. Also ich weiß, wie wir uns 2000 den Mund fusselig geredet haben, wie ätzend wir das finden, dass jetzt diese ganzen Stadien umbenannt werden. Dass nicht mehr Alm und Betzenberg – oder Betzenberg ist ja tatsächlich sogar noch Fritz-Weiter-Stadion, aber dass die Alm nicht mehr Alm heißt und das Volksparkstadion nicht mehr Volksparkstadion und das Waldstadion dann Commerzbank Arena wird und so weiter. Also dass die alle heißen wie Firmenparkplätze, das fanden wir natürlich ätzend. Der Punkt ist nur, wenn du das heutzutage Leuten erzählst oder wenn wir zum Beispiel auf unsere Stadionposter noch die alten Namen draufschreiben, da gibt es echt viele, die sagen, Leute, das sind Diskussionen aus dem vergangenen Jahrhundert. Das ist nicht mehr unser Thema. Das Gleiche ist so bei so Themen wie Stehplätzen. Da, glaube ich, gibt es inzwischen ein allgemeines Agreement in der Liga, dass es eine gewisse Masse an Stehplätzen geben soll. Und selbst wenn es immer mal wieder durchgeknallte Innenminister gibt, die sagen, die schaffen wir jetzt mal als nächstes ab, glaube ich, will das niemand in der Liga, weil die Leute kapiert haben, dass dort eine andere Kultur herrscht als auf den Sitzplätzen. Aber ich glaube, insgesamt war es für Elf-Freunde einfach wichtig zu schauen, dass es ganz, ganz viele unterschiedliche Arten gibt, Fußball zu lieben und auch dieser Fußballkultur authentisch Ausdruck zu geben. Und dass es schade wäre, wenn wir sagen, Fan-Themen sind das Einzige, was wir so machen wollen. Insofern war es für uns wichtig, dass wir uns auch mit den Akteuren des Spiels unterhalten. So einer wie Mats Hummels zum Beispiel, jetzt in der aktuellen Ausgabe. Mit dem reden wir ja gar nicht so wahnsinnig viel darüber, wie er sich nun im System von Favre sieht, sondern wir reden mit dem auch darüber, wie er sich zur AfD positioniert. Und wir reden mit ihm darüber, warum er der österreichischen Publizistin Natascha Strobl folgt, die ihrerseits auf Twitter ja diese ganz großartigen Analysen von diesem ganzen, ganzen rechtsnationalen Wahnsinn macht. Also ich fände es total schade, uns selbst zu beschränken und zu sagen, wir reden nicht mit Mats Hummels, weil das wird ja eh blöd, sondern ich glaube, dass gute Interviews und gute Vorbereitung und Interesse am Gegenüber und Interesse am Spieler und auch an anderen dazu führen kann, dass auch Spieler was Intelligentes sagen. Und gerade das Interview mit Mats Hummels ist dafür meiner Meinung nach auch ein Beleg, dass das funktionieren kann.
Und trotzdem haben sich ja so ein bisschen die Medien-Nutzungsarten verändert.
Ich habe gar nicht auf deine Frage geantwortet, ne?
Der alte Politiker Köster ist da wieder rausgekommen.
Dann sage ich noch einen einzigen Satz und dann darf Jakob rein. Also die Medien-Nutzung hat sich natürlich verändert. Es gibt doch diese Szene bei diesem Facebook-Film, wo einer der beiden Gründer, Eduardo Severin, irgendwie dann mit diesem Napster-Gründer aneinandergerät. Und dann sagt der Napster-Gründer zu ihm noch, pass mal auf, wenn du jetzt was machen würdest, du würdest auch keinen Plattenladen gründen. Ich glaube, als es darum ging, ob Napstern Erfolg war. Und ich glaube, genauso ist es eben auch bei dem Printmagazin. Man wird jetzt heute auch keinen Kiosk aufmachen, weil man denkt, das ist jetzt eine total geile Sache, weil das ist jetzt irgendwie das Geschäft der Zukunft. Natürlich hat sich das alles geändert. Und natürlich gibt es immer weniger Präsenz für Printmagazine. Wenn ich heute von Prenzlauer Berg nach Friedrichshain fahre, ist es immer so, dass nahezu bei jedem Trip darunter ein Kiosk mehr zugemacht hat oder ein Kiosk weniger Elfreunde führt, weil die nur noch so ein paar Brigitte, Sternen und die Tageszeitungen haben. Also ich glaube schon, wir als Ballestra, als Elfreunde, als auch andere Printmagazine müssen uns natürlich dem stell, dass die Leute eher ins Internet gucken, wenn sie was Neues wissen wollen und dass es im Internet inzwischen auch unfassbar viele tolle Sachen gibt. Ich glaube, keines der beiden Magazine verweigert sich ja dem Internet. Also wir sind da ja beide sehr aktiv. Insofern ist das schon alles okay so.
Na gut, aber das Geldverdienen ist halt so viel schwieriger im Internet. Also ihr habt natürlich zum Beispiel mit dem Live-Ticker sogar – da hat es ja sogar etwas aus dem Internet irgendwann ins Heft geschafft. Das ist ja das perfekte Paradoxon. Aber dennoch begegnest du im Internet eben der Realität, dass es viel, viel schwieriger ist, noch Geld zu verdienen, weil die Anzeigenpreise völlig versaut sind durch die Durchanalysierbarkeit jedweder Daten und dann wird – dann werden da ganz fürchterliche Ads geschaltet, damit überhaupt noch irgendjemand da draufklickt. Amerikanische Forscher haben herausgefunden, so nehmen sie 100 Kilo ab in zwei Tagen und so ein Kram. Und auf der anderen Seite gibt es zwar die Bewegung, dass Leute durchaus bereit sind, auch im Internet Geld für Dienstleistungen zu bezahlen. Der Rasenfunk ist da ja auch ein ganz kleines Beispiel. Aber da steht halt ein unglaublicher Aufwand dahinter, das anzuschieben. Also noch ist das nicht einfach nur, hey, wir schalten jetzt hier unser Magazin auch in eine Online-Variante verfügbar und dann rollt der Rubel auch digital rein. So einfach ist es ja noch nicht.
Nein, ich glaube, das wird überhaupt nicht funktionieren. Ich glaube auch, es gibt eine Printkrise und ich glaube, es tun sich alle Magazine gerade schwer. Aber ich glaube, es gibt auch eine Online-Krise. Also es gibt für Unabhängigen, Kritischen vielleicht auch etwas längeren, hintergründigeren Journalismus im Internet, kein Geschäftsmodell. Also wenn man sich anschaut, wir haben das auch im aktuellen Heft irgendwie kurz drin, Republik in der Schweiz. Tolles Projekt, tolle Leute dahinter, super durchfinanziert irgendwie das erste Jahr. Da kann man sagen, ok, eigentlich von dem, was sie da anbieten wollen, alles großartig und ja, man merkt, diese Texte funktionieren dort auch nicht. Das heißt, mit dem Internet muss man anders umgehen. Also ich glaube, zu sagen, wir transferieren den Balesterer ins Netz, ich glaube, das funktioniert gar nicht. Ich glaube, man kann sich überlegen, wie schauen, wie kann ein Internet auftreten und das Heft sich gut ergänzen. Also wie das Beispiel jetzt von dir auch, wenn es da Synergien gibt, wenn das eine und das andere wechseln und so weiter, super, dann toll gemacht. Aber im Prinzip glaube ich, dass es auch sehr schwer gerade ist, einen Blog zu gründen oder eine Webseite zu gründen, die jetzt von Werbeeinnahmen oder was auch immer allein lebt. Also ich glaube, das funktioniert ohne irgendwie ein Unterstützungsmodell oder so, wenn man nicht irgendwie nur auf Clickbait setzt.
Das glaube ich auch. Und natürlich ist es manchmal ein Glücksfall, wenn einem irgendetwas gelingt, was ein bisschen stilprägend ist. Also das war bei uns ja vor allen Dingen der Live-Ticker, der ja dann auch vielfältig kopiert worden ist. Also diese neue Form des Journalismus und eben nicht nur 102030 zu vermelden. Aber mir hat das mal ein gruner Mitarbeiter bitter vorgerechnet, was so die Kapitalisierung angeht. Dass du tatsächlich von 100 Euro, die du für eine Print-Anzeige einnehmen würdest, also was die Kontakte angeht, dafür bleiben dann beim Desktop, also auf dem stationären Computer, noch 10 Euro und im mobilen Web bleiben dir 1 Euro bei gleichzeitiger Leistung so. Und ich glaube, dass dieser Geburtsfehler oder ich würde mal sagen, dass diese Unwucht gerade für Magazine und auch für Verlage, die von der Rentabilität von Printprodukten leben, nicht einfach ist. Du siehst, du kannst das, was du vorher eingenommen hast, nicht annähernd wieder reinholen. Deswegen gibt es glaube ich auch ganz viele Verlage, die die Digitalisierung so lange verschleppen, wie es nur irgendwie geht, in der Hoffnung, dass die Magazine noch weiter irgendwie Geld einbringen.
Und wie ist das jetzt dann in dem Fall von euren beiden Heften gelagert? Also ich nehme jetzt einfach mal an, Philipp, dass es bei euch so sein wird, dass das Durchschnittsalter der Abonnenten, die die wichtigste Käufergruppe sind, dass das eher steigt, als dass es sinkt. Was ja, wenn man jetzt den Zeitraum von den nächsten fünf Jahren vielleicht mal aufmacht, nicht einfach nur von Monat oder von Quartal zu Quartal denkt, irgendwann zu einem Problem werden könnte. Wie könnt ihr das denn schaffen, diesem Trend entgegenzustehen?
Also tatsächlich ist die nicht überaltert. Also die sterben jetzt nicht weg, unsere Abonnenten. Wir sind nicht die CDU und wir sind nicht der Gong. Da haben wir tatsächlich, glaube ich, den Vorteil, dass Fußball Gott sei Dank ja eine lebenslange Beschäftigung ist. Aber es ist natürlich so, dass wir, was so das Printmagazin angeht, eine Zielgruppe haben, die erst so ab 30 anfängt. Das ist echt vollkommen anders als im Internet. Also das muss man echt mal sagen. Es kommen wahnsinnig viele Leute zu unserer Lesung zum Beispiel, die uns vor allen Dingen über den Live-Ticker, vor allen Dingen übers Internet kennen. Wir haben auch schon Praktikanten gehabt, die total überrascht waren, dass wir nicht nur eine Facebook-Seite sind. Da ist man doch auch immer mal wieder überrascht. Aber tatsächlich ist es noch mal so, dass das Genre des Zeitschriften-Abos als solches jetzt nicht das hippste Produkt ist, das man so irgendwie verkaufen kann. Also es gibt Leute, die das schätzen. Es gibt auch junge Leute, die das schätzen. Aber so, dass das wie früher wäre, wo jeder, der irgendwie zu Hause auszog, als allererstes von seinen Eltern die Lokalzeitung im Abo bekommen hat und wo es ganz selbstverständlich war, dass man sich so zwei, drei Blätter gehalten hat. Ich glaube, dass die Zeiten vorbei sind. Man muss heute um jeden Abonnenten ringen. Und deswegen ist es eigentlich auch für uns schon frühzeitig eher ein Modell gewesen, zu sagen, wir wollen gar nicht, dass die nur Abonnenten sind, sondern die sollen eigentlich näher an uns ranrücken. Weil wir natürlich auch feststellen, dass wir von ganz, ganz vielen Leuten, die uns abonniert haben, die Ideen haben, die neue Sichtweisen haben, wir auch sehr profitieren können. Ich glaube, das ist eigentlich sogar das, was für mich durch die Digitalisierung als allergreifbarste Vorteil ist, dass diese eindimensionale Senderhaltung, die vorher Magazine hatten, dass man nur Sachen aussendet und hofft, dass das Gefallen bringt, sich in einen Dialog gewandelt hat. Das finde ich eigentlich das Allerbeste, dass man viele, viele neue Perspektiven kennenlernt, Leute, die ihre Stimme erheben können. Das ist eigentlich sogar, finde ich, wenn ich jetzt zu den Vorteilen der Digitalisierung betrachten würde, dass aus einem monologen Dialog geworden ist eigentlich sogar das erhebendste und spannendste.
Aber müsst ihr dann nicht zwangsläufig auch ein bisschen weg irgendwann vom Kern des Printprodukts – also du hast ja schon gesagt, dass ihr Abonnenten besonders binden wollt, das ergibt ja auch Sinn – aber die müssen ja immer noch die Liebe zu einem Printprodukt haben, die ja nicht mehr so weit verbreitet ist wie früher noch vielleicht.
Nee, eigentlich nicht. Also eigentlich wird das ja schon so sein, dass – das ist ja absehbar – dass du natürlich alles, was du momentan bei uns im Heft liest, auch digital lesen kannst. Du kannst ja heute natürlich schon irgendwie so Emacs und so weiter runterladen, ob es dann als PDF ist oder auch als aufbereitete Variante. Aber entscheidend wird schon sein, dass du natürlich irgendwie eigentlich nicht mehr unbedingt dir das haptische Heft liefern lassen musst, um mehr Freundeabonnent zu sein. Also das war ja so ein bisschen das Prinzip, dass wir mit dieser Dauerkarte haben, also dass wir sagen, pass mal auf, wenn du das Ding dir holst, dann kannst du natürlich auch alles, alles, alles, ohne dass du einmal irgendwie das Heft in die Hand nehmen musst, natürlich auch digital lesen. Nur, ich sag, also für mich ist das ja so, ich bin seit ich zwölf oder dreizehn bin von Magazinen fasziniert. Also ich wollte nie was anderes machen, also ich wusste so mit zwölf, dreizehn, dass ich irgendwie so in diesen Magazinjournalismus will. Und ich hab nach wie vor, ich würd's nicht sagen, kein erotisches Verhältnis zum Magazin machen, aber tatsächlich finde ich nichts aufregender, als wenn bei uns der Postbote endlich kommt und unsere Hefte in die Redaktion bringt und wir das aufmachen. Ja, es ist ein erotisches Verhältnis. Wie so ein Print-Tinder-Date quasi. Also ich finde das nach wie vor immer den aufregendsten Moment, das Ding rauszuholen, durchzublättern, das in der Hand zu haben, zu gucken, wie funktioniert die Heftmischung, fühlen sich die Leser da gut durchgeleitet. Also mir würde was sehr, sehr fehlen, wenn wir irgendwann alle Freunde nur noch digital hätten und nicht als Heft, dass du dir auch in den Schrank stellen kannst und dass du durchblättern kannst und das auf deinem Schreibtisch oder auf deinem Nachttisch liegt.
Jakob, bei euch ist die Situation ja logischerweise etwas extremer gerade, deswegen ja auch die Ballesterer-Rentkampagne. Wie würdest du sagen, hat sich bei euch das niedergeschlagen, dass sich der Markt für Fußballmagazine verändert hat? Und welchen Weg daraus gibt's?
Ja, ich glaube, dass der Markt einfach von von vornherein schwierig war und seit 20 Jahren schwierig ist. Also da gibt es halt auch nochmal den großen Unterschied natürlich zwischen den unterschiedlichen Märkten in Österreich und Deutschland und auch den großen Unterschied, wie populär ist Fußball in den jeweiligen Ländern? Also ich glaube, dass man da einfach ganz andere Entwicklungen natürlich auch sieht.
Also der Wedler, das Skisportmagazin, wäre erfolgreicher als der Ballester?
Skifix ist die Idee. Na, na, Skifix haben wir schon diejenigen, die aus anderen Bundesländern aus Wien kommen, schon geplant. Nein, glaube ich auch nicht. Also Fußball ist schon der populärste Sport in Österreich, aber es ist halt trotzdem nicht so ein Massenphänomen wie in Deutschland, wo irgendwie jedes Stadion bis in die dritte Liga hinein voll ist. Bei uns gibt es halt ein paar Stadien, die gut gefüllt sind, aber auch alles sehr starken Schwankungen immer unterworfen. Prinzipiell, ich glaube, was diese Frage Online-Print betrifft, ich glaube schon, dass das Magazine oder Special-Interest-Magazine, vor allem Special-Interest-Magazine, eigentlich diejenigen sind, die für die Printkrise am besten gewappnet sind, weil es da sowieso nicht um Tagesaktualität geht. Das heißt, jemand, der sich dafür entscheidet, die L-Freunde oder einen Ballestra zu kaufen, der macht das nicht, weil er irgendein Matchergebnis haben will oder weil er über die neuesten Nachrichten des Tages informiert werden will, wie jemand, der eine Tageszeitung kauft. Also ich glaube, dass wir da schon einen Vorteil haben und ich glaube auch, dass es Leute gibt, die dieses haptische, also da Philipp hat jetzt dieses erotische Verhältnis genannt, ich glaube, dass das gar nicht nur diejenigen haben, die das Magazin produzieren, sondern ich glaube, dass das auch den Lesern und Leserinnen von Magazinen oft so geht. Also die wollen was in der Hand haben, die wollen sich das anschauen, die wollen das lesen oder vielleicht auch nicht alles lesen. Also es liegt dann oft einmal ein Monat herum und vielleicht packt man es in zwei Monaten wieder aus oder wir riechen und man schaut nochmal rein. Und ich glaube, dass das was ist, was auch eben im Print nach wie vor funktioniert. Ich glaube, dass es natürlich ein Problem gibt, wenn es viele Leute gibt, die an das gar nicht mehr gewöhnt sind oder wenn man sagt, es wird einfach weniger Zeit und gelesen. Ich glaube, dass man das online halt auch irgendwie mitbespielen muss. Aber ich glaube auch, dass es – ich weiß nicht, wie ich das formulieren soll, aber ich glaube, das was wir können und das was wir in den letzten 20 Jahren gelernt haben, ist, ein Printmagazin zu machen mit hintergründigen Texten, mit Schwerpunkten, das versucht irgendwie ein oder viele Themen, die mit dem Fußball zu tun haben, die bestmöglich zu beachten. Ich glaube, wenn man jetzt sagt, okay, wir wollen jetzt schauen, wie können wir, irgendwie weil sich die Lesegewohnheiten verändert haben, ist für mich die Frage, wie können wir das übersetzen, wie können wir das, was wir jetzt können, auch in anderen Bereichen bestmöglich machen. Was aber nicht geht ist zu sagen, okay, und wir konkurrieren jetzt mit irgendeinem lustigen Online-Medium, das irgendwie schaut, was alle paar Minuten neu rauskommt und was die letzte Transfer-Marktspekulation oder was auch immer ist. Also ich glaube, man muss da noch einen Weg finden, wie man Leute ansprechen kann. Prinzipiell glaube ich, dass der Ballesterer geschätzt wird für die Themen und für die Sicht und für das, wie er Themen anschaut und ich glaube, da muss man halt schauen, gibt es da Arten, wie man das besser machen kann, wenn sich der Markt so verändert. Das ist schwieriger. Mir hat das Bild von Philipp vorher mit dem Dialog gefallen. Man kann vielleicht sogar einen Polilog draus machen. Ich würde sagen, man tritt mit den Leserinnen auch Stärke in ein Verhältnis. Also ich würde auch sagen, dass das für den Ballesterer immer was total Wesentliches war. Ich würde sagen, wir rekrutieren uns vor allem neu auch aus Lesern und Leserinnen. Wir haben nicht diese professionellen Strukturen, wo man sagt, du musst jetzt irgendwie Publizistik studiert haben oder die FA gemacht haben, dann vier Praktika gemacht haben und bei so und so viele Zeitungen schon gearbeitet haben, um für uns schreiben zu können, sondern die meisten Leute, die neu dazukommen, kommen darüber, dass sie sich für den Ballester irgendwie interessieren. Dazu habe ich jetzt ein bisschen den Faden verloren, wo ich eigentlich hinwollte.
Daraus wird der Polilog aus dem Dialog?
Genau, einen Dialog oder einen Polilog gibt es sowieso schon. Ich hoffe, dass dieser Supporters Club, den wir jetzt neu gegründet haben, wo Leute teilnehmen können, denen das ein Herzensanliegen ist, dass es den Ballesterer weiter gibt, die dafür auch eine kleine Spende, eine monatliche, machen und dass wir speziell mit denen auch in einen starken Austausch kommen und davon auch sehr viel profitieren. Was ist das, was diese Leute dann auch wollen? Was ist das, was wir machen können? Und vielleicht sind da auch Leute dabei, die dann eben auch die Seite wechseln und von Lesern oder Fans von uns dann vielleicht auch zu Schreibern oder Schreiberinnen werden und so weiter.
Philipp, du hast ja wahrscheinlich auch noch meine eigene Sicht drauf, weil es in den 20 Jahren 11Freunde auch immer wieder im deutschsprachigen Markt direkte Konkurrenten gab, kurzzeitig von 11Freunde. Also es gab mal aus dem Olympia Verlag, ich glaube, das war rund damals, es gab verschiedene andere Formate. Woran liegt es denn deiner Meinung nach, dass bis auf 11Freunde und vielleicht noch den tödlichen Pass, aber ich weiß nicht, ob man den dazurechnen soll, weil das eben in einer komplett anderen Dimension abläuft, aber den gibt es schon länger, ich glaube seit 1995 hier aus München heraus produziert. Woran liegt es, dass keiner sich auf diesem Markt behaupten konnte? Wie habt ihr die vom Markt rausgedrängt, Philipp? Pferdeköpfe in Betten?
Nein, ich glaube tatsächlich, dass das große Problem war, dass ich vorhin schon mal angerissen habe, da entscheidend war, nämlich diese Überschätzung des Marktes. Der Olympia-Verlag ist ja damals mit rund in den Andi-Kiosk gegangen und dann gab es noch Player aus dem B&D-Verlag, die beide, glaube ich, dachten, hey, Fußballmarkt illustrierte großes Interesse, weltweites und bundesweites Interesse, das muss doch funktionieren. Und dann haben sie eben festgestellt, wie schwierig dieser Markt eigentlich ist und wie schwer es eigentlich ist, neben Sportbild, neben Kicker und dann auch eben uns überhaupt zu einer Art von Rentabilität zu kommen. Und man darf nicht vergessen, dass zu der Zeit Magazinengeschäft damals auch noch anders betrieben wurde. Also damals war man mit Auflagen unter 100.000 völlig unzufrieden. Damals galt alles, was so 30, 40, 50.000 Exemplare verkauft in Deutschland, als total floppt. Und das war zum Beispiel auch der Grund, warum dieses großartige Magazin Hetrick, das es ja in den 90ern gab, von Christoph Biermann und anderen gemacht, dann nicht zu Gruner und Jahr gegangen ist, weil die auch damals noch auf dem Trip waren, dass sie gesagt haben, hey, alles, was nicht 100.000 verkauft, da müsste ja gar nicht mit ankommen. Und ich glaube, dass dann irgendwann diese Verlage gesehen haben, hey, da steckt ja gar kein großes, geiles Geschäft hinter, wie wir uns das vorgestellt haben, sondern das ist mühsam und da muss man immer wieder um jede Anzeige kämpfen und so weiter. Das lassen wir doch lieber. Und dann haben eben Verlage schnell die Lust verloren. Das war bei uns eben anders, weil wir es schon ganz klein kannten, weil wir ja sehr organisch gewachsen sind. Die anderen Magazine hatten dann immer so einen relativ schnell großen Apparat mit 10 Redakteuren, 12 Grafikern, 14 Marketingleuten und so. Also ich glaube, das war jetzt nicht so, dass wir mit aggressiven Marketing, die vom Tableau gewischt hätten, sondern eher, die sind an ihren eigenen Ansprüchen und an ihren eigenen möglicherweise Überschätzungen gescheitert. Wobei ich ehrlich gesagt auch finde, ich habe Rund immer gerne gelesen, ich habe den Player immer gerne gelesen, obwohl der ja auch eher ein Magazin war, Oliver Desk war, vom Kollegen Oliver Wurm. Also ich habe das immer gerne gelesen und ich glaube auch, dass noch weitere Magazine neben uns, neben dem Ballesterer durchaus guttäten am Markt. Also ich finde, wir haben ja alle unsere speziellen Ausformungen. Es gibt Dinge, die wir besonders gerne machen, es gibt Dinge, die der Ballesterer besonders gut kann. Also da wäre es eigentlich super, wenn es zum Beispiel noch etwas gäbe, was zum Beispiel wie 442 früher eher richtig Boulevardesque wäre, das quasi dann auch nochmal andere Geschichten erzählt. Also ich glaube, dass eine lebendige Print-Szene und eine lebendige Magazinszene eigentlich allen gut tun würde. Aber wie gesagt, da gibt es glaube ich auch jetzt nicht gerade das ganz große Interesse der Verlage zu sagen. Da ballern wir jetzt noch mal mit einem abweiteren Fußmagazin auf dem Markt.
Ja, ich glaube, für Verlage da reinzugehen, das ist schwierig. Es ist auch in Österreich – wir waren immer das Einzige, oder nicht immer das Einzige, es gab mal 08, auch ein schönes Magazin, das ich auch gern gelesen habe. Aber es sind mittlerweile in Österreich auch alle anderen Sportmagazine mehr oder weniger eingestellt worden. Also Wochenzeitungen, Monatszeitungen, was auch immer. Also ich glaube, dass alles, was von Verlagen kommt, die einfach mal glauben, okay, wir puttern da jetzt ein bisschen was rein und das wird schon funktionieren. Ich glaube, dass das so nicht funktioniert. Ich glaube, es hat zwar immer geheißen, jetzt Magazine gründen, das muss irgendwie verrückt sein, aber ich finde, wenn ich mir anschaue zum Beispiel, was die Kollegen und Kolleginnen von Zeitspielen in Deutschland machen, finde ich auch eine super Bereicherung. Also es ist ein schönes Magazin und würde ich auch sagen, hat auf dem Markt Platz. Und das, was der Philipp vorhin gesagt hat, würde ich da auch nochmal unterschreiben. Wir sind zwar in irgendeiner Form Konkurrenz, weil wir beide Fußballmagazine sind, aber es gibt eigentlich relativ wenige Überschneidungen, was die Ausrichtung. Oder auch die Themen unterscheidet sich oft sehr stark. Das ist meistens eine Ergänzung und nicht ein so muss man es machen. Der Fußball und sein Umfeld bieten so viele schöne Möglichkeiten, über den Sport, über die Welt, über die Gesellschaft zu sprechen, dass da auch viele nebeneinander existieren können, ohne dass man sich jetzt sagt, man kannibalisiert sich da irgendwie.
Kann ich aus persönlicher Erfahrung auch sagen, man kann beides parallel sehr gut lesen und hat nicht das Gefühl, dass man da irgendetwas doppelt lesen würde. Aber gleichzeitig haben wir ja auch die Entwicklung, wenn ihr jetzt sagt, naja, es wäre eigentlich auch schön, noch ein weiteres Magazin zu haben, das vielleicht einen anderen Schwerpunkt legt. Als du zum Beispiel gesagt hast, Philipp, das war das Thema, die man noch mal aus einem anderen Blickwinkel sieht, da war mein erster Gedanke, naja, das kriegt man ja als Fan schon. Da muss ich ja nur den Leuten auf Instagram folgen. Und wenn ich ausführliche Artikel oder Interviews mit Spielern lesen will von meiner Lieblingsmannschaft, dann gucke ich mir Vereinszeitschriften an und die sehen ja inzwischen aus wie Freunde doof gesagt. Also, das soll jetzt nicht als Beleidigung verstanden sein, aber die versuchen ja auch, sich den Anklang zu geben. Jedes kostenlose Magazin, eben keine Ahnung, DM oder in der Deutschen Bahn, wird heutzutage hergestellt von irgendeiner Agentur, die darauf spezialisiert ist, die dann auch richtige Journalisten dafür bezahlt, da mehr oder weniger tiefgehende Stücke für zu produzieren. Also, ich habe das Gefühl, jetzt aus Sicht des Fußballfans, der das konsumiert, gibt es doch eigentlich gerade schon alles und vielleicht ist das auch Teil des Problems.
Ja, ist es definitiv. Ich finde auch, es ist schon eine gewisse Chuzpe von den Vereinen, ständig Interviews mit ihren Spielern auf ihren Vereinskanälen als exklusiv anzupreisen. Denn natürlich haben sie das exklusiv. Es sind ja ihre Spieler und es sind ihre Kanäle. Und natürlich ist es so, dass vieles dann von außen aussieht, wie wir. Also, wenn ich mir das neue Vereinsmagazin vom FC Bayern anschaue, ist das tatsächlich ein Magazin, von dem ich denke, da kannst du auch 11 Freunde draufpappen und ein bisschen weniger PR im Berichterstattung, dann wäre es zumindest von der Grafik und von der Gestaltung und sehr, sehr ähnlich. Da denke ich halt immer schon, das ist dann schwierig für uns nochmal die Absetzbewegung zu machen. Ich glaube, du kannst dich eigentlich nur retten durch Unabhängigkeit, durch kritischen Journalismus, durch immer wieder Unbequem sein, weil das ist eigentlich das Einzige, was die nicht liefern, nämlich Distanz und Journalismus, klassischen Journalismus, der nicht durch Vereinsbrille oder PR-Brille gefärbt ist. Und vielleicht noch ein zweites ist tatsächlich bei uns zumindest, bei den Freunde eben auch Humor. Der kommt sicherlich bei uns manchmal auch ein bisschen studentisch daher, gerade im Netz so. Aber ich glaube trotz allem, dass in diesen ganzen Magazinen und auf den Instagram-Kanälen und so weiter eines eben nicht passiert, nämlich diesen ganzen klebrigen Pathos, der irgendwie den Fußball ja umwabert, den zu brechen und an der Realität zu überprüfen und zu schauen, stimmt das denn wirklich so? Das ist eben was, was kein Vereinsmagazin und kein Instagram-Account leistet, sondern das können dann doch eben nur Magazine wie El Freunde und Balestra oder das können dann auch nur Portale, wie es jetzt beispielsweise Spielverlagerungen ist oder das können eben auch nur so Podcastsachen wie Rasenfunk und andere. Also dieses ironisch, selbstironisch Punk-Rockesk, diese Sachen zu spiegeln, das ist eben eine Sache, das kriegt dann doch eben kein Kanal und kein Vereinsmagazin hin.
Der Humor als Absatzbewegung. Ja, ist so ein bisschen die Frage. Auf der anderen Seite hat ja jeder so, also das ist ja gerade die Gefahr oder was heißt Gefahr, aber das zeichnet das ja aus, dass man sich sehr für die eigene Sache begeistert, dass ich glaube, dass es auch in beim Rasenfunk, beim Ballestere, als auch bei Freunde gibt es auch wiederum Themengebiete, wo uns andere dann vorwerfen konnten, naja, da habt ihr dann vielleicht auch einen besonderen Pathos. Also bei mir wäre es dann wahrscheinlich der Fokus total auf Taktik und wo man sich dann eben auch überdreht und dann das leichte Abkippen des Außenverteidigers wichtiger findet, als dass jemand ein Eigentor geschossen hat, jetzt doof gesagt. Und bei Freunden und Ballestere ist es vielleicht auch gerade dieser Rückgriff auf die auf die gute alte Zeit in Anführungszeichen jetzt zu versehen, wo auch Leute sagen könnten, naja, da habt ihr ja auch euren Bereich, wo ihr so fest dran hängt. Also ich bin mir da manchmal gar nicht so sicher. Ich möchte dir gerne zustimmen. Ich bin mir aber nicht sicher, ob ich, ob ich mich jetzt also zum Beispiel den Rasenfunk, ob man den da so komplett rausnehmen könnte. Wenn man halt für eine Sache brennt, dann stürzt man sich da so drauf und überdreht halt auch. Und ob da dann immer noch für jeden auch mal die ironische Distanz dazu zu sehen ist, weiß ich nicht.
Also ist bei uns tatsächlich so. Ich sehe auch so blinde Flecke. Also ich würde noch nicht mal sagen, dass wir die Vergangenheit per se verklären. Aber es ist natürlich so, dass manches von dem, was uns heute noch als gute alte Zeit erscheint, also tatsächlich so diese 80er, 70er Jahre, die – was die 80er Jahre angeht – für mich natürlich auch verklärt sind als die Zeit, in der ich zum Fußball gefunden habe und die ich auch deswegen noch besonders intensiv in Erinnerung habe, weil sie halt diese Neuentdeckung eines wahnsinnig aufregenden Gebietes für mich war. Also für mich war es, als ich das erste Mal auf die Alm gegangen bin in Bielefeld, unfassbar aufregend, dass da viele, viele tausend Leute auf den Rängen stehen und Schimpfworte brüllen und rauchen und Bier trinken und sich gegenschmeißen lassen. Also das war tatsächlich für mich eine Welt, die ich damals staunend und fasziniert und begeistert so wahrgenommen habe und da muss man quasi es mir nachsehen, dass ich darauf jetzt nicht den knallharten soziologischen, historischen, sozialwissenschaftlichen Blick habe, dass ich sezieren kann, dass du natürlich in den 80ern auch viel Rassismus auf den Rängen gehabt hast, dass das die Hochzeit der Hooligans war, dass das die Hochzeit von chauvinistischen Sprüchen war. Ja, stimmt alles. Es war aber für mich ganz persönlich dann eben doch das, was Klaus Teweleit-Mator zur Welt genannt hat. Also Erklärmodell, all das. Also von daher hat da jeder seinen blinden Fleck. Das mag für dich die Taktik sein oder Faszination von taktischen Systemen. Das war für mich sicher diese Zeit, in der man das so kennengelernt hat. Das hat, glaube ich, jeder. Und ja, da muss man mit leben und muss irgendwann möglicherweise trotz allem aus dieser Verklärung raus. Aber das ist wahrscheinlich ein lebenslanger Prozess für uns alle.
Ja, ich sehe die Verklärung oder ich sehe das Problem nicht so groß. Also ich glaube schon, dass es das natürlich gibt und dass sich das dann auch in den Kreisen, in denen wir halt irgendwie gerade, die dann vielleicht redaktionelle Entscheidungen treffen oder so, dass da natürlich blinde Flecken da sind. Ich glaube, dass da wichtig ist, was wir vorher schon gesagt haben, eben diesen Austausch auch nach außen oder mit einer größeren Gruppe und auch den internen. Das ist ein Austausch in der in der Redaktion, ja. Also wenn man sagt, okay, ich weiß, ich hab da vielleicht einen blinden Fleck, dann schau ich drauf, dass vielleicht jemand, der da speziell sensibel drauf ist, über den Text schaut, den ich zu dem Thema schreib.
Ja, okay, gut, klar, das stimmt, aber vielleicht muss ich noch ein bisschen erklären, wie ich zu der Frage komme. Also dass ich mich zum Beispiel im Rasenfunk so auf Analyse fokussiere, das hängt ja nicht damit zusammen, dass ich mit einer Taktik-Tafel auf die Welt gekommen wäre. Ganz im Gegenteil, Philipp, du hast mich 2008 noch erlebt. Da hatte ich auch noch einen anderen Blick auf Fußball. Ich weiß nicht, welche Erinnerungen du hast, aber ich weiß noch, also ich weiß noch, dass ich da auch noch lange Haare hatte im ersten Teil meines Praktikums. Es ist wirklich schon ewig lange her. Aber der Grund, warum ich mich da so drauf fokussiere, ist, weil mich so viel anderes am Fußball so wahnsinnig nervt und ich das so wahnsinnig irrelevant finde. Und deswegen fokussiere ich mich auf die Taktik, also sprich, weil alles drumherum so ätzend ist oder vieles davon einfach ätzend geworden ist, suche ich mir diesen einen Bereich, der eben auch noch sehr viel mit dem Sport zu tun hat. Und ich liebe halt einfach das Spiel Fußball, sowohl es zu spielen als auch es zu gucken. Und daher kommt so ein bisschen meine Sorge. Und klar, ihr habt natürlich Mechanismen, um eure blinden Flecken nicht so sehr durchscheinen zu lassen auf eure Produkte. Das stimmt. Aber was machen wir drei denn, wenn der Fußball sich weiter so entwickelt, dass er einfach in vielen Bereichen einfach nur noch ätzend ist und man eigentlich gar keine Lust mehr hat, sich damit zu beschäftigen?
Also ich bin ja Kulturoptimist bei so was. Also ich glaube halt, dass es natürlich trotz allem immer Nischen geben wird. Der geschätzte Kollege Pascal Kloth von knapp daneben in der Schweiz, der hat mal ein wunderbares Buch rausgegeben über die Flachpassbar im Stadion von Zürich. Da wurde einfach das kulturelle Leben in dieser Stadionkneipe geschildert und man bekam in diesem Buch einen wunderbaren Blick darauf, wie Fußball funktionieren kann als Begegnungsstätte. Und er hat darin zwei Sätze formuliert, die ich ganz beeindruckend fand, nämlich er hat sich gefragt, was wir im Fußball eigentlich suchen und die zweite Frage, ob wir das, was wir im Fußball suchen, in Zukunft noch auch im Fußball finden werden und ich glaube, das ist so tatsächlich die entscheidende Frage, die wir uns alle stellen müssen. Was suchen wir denn eigentlich und finden wir das beim Fußball? Und ich habe bei all dem, was passiert ist, bei all dem, was an Kommerzialisierung passiert ist, an Versitzplatzung, an Preisschilds überall dran gehängt und so und an Eventisierung und an Fahnenpässen und Sky, Superclash, Gigantenbewerbung und so weiter, habe ich trotz allem, trotz allem im Fußball immer noch wunderbare Momente erlebt, ob es mit Aminia ist oder ob es vom Fernseher ist oder mit Freunden und so weiter. Fußball gibt mir immer noch viel, viel, viel zu viel, als dass ich irgendwie auch nur andersweise daran denken würde, ey mir reicht es jetzt oder ich gehe nur noch in die Kreisliga. Also das ist tatsächlich am Ende dann ja auch, glaube ich, so eine Entscheidung, ob man diesen ganzen Scheiß, den es drum herum gibt, diese ganzen Nervereien, diese ganze Geldgier, diese ganzen gierigen Funktionäre mit Dollarzeichen in den Augen, ob man das aushält, weil man sagt, der Fußball an sich ist trotzdem so großartig, so wunderbar und für mich so wichtig im Leben oder ob man dann irgendwann so zynisch wird und sagt, ja leck mich doch am Arsch. Das ist alles nichts mehr für mich. Also die Tendenz gibt es ja auch und die Leute gibt es ja auch. Also ich kenne viele, die sagen, hey, Muffi-Fußball, kein Bock mehr. Kann ich auch verstehen, für mich ist es aber irgendwie keine Alternative, ich komme da nicht raus quasi.
Stockholmsyndrom.
Ich glaube auch, dass es da zwei Aspekte gibt, also der eine Aspekt ist quasi, wie geht es einem persönlich, also dir oder dem Philipp oder mir mit dem Fußball und das andere ist halt, wie geht es dem Medium mit dem Thema. Und da würde ich sagen, wenn der Fußball nicht auch so scheiße wäre, dann gäbe es unsere Medien nicht. Also das ist ja, das war ja irgendwie so schon Gründungsmotivation, also das ist ja das, was wir auch am Anfang besprochen haben quasi, zu sagen, okay, uns war von Beginn an wichtig, zu sagen, wir sind gegen diese Kommerzialisierung, die es im Fußball gibt oder wir sind gegen, weiß ich nicht, Stehplatzverbot oder was auch immer. Das heißt, es gab ja immer schon das Bedürfnis, Kritik zu üben und Kritik an den Zuständen, die jetzt sind. Und ich würde sagen, das wird nicht weniger, so wie sich der Fußball entwickelt. Also dieses Bedürfnis zu sagen, okay, so wie es rennt, geht es oder das ist nicht gut, so wie es läuft. Ich glaube, dass das heute noch mindestens genauso, wenn nicht viel mehr, gilt als vor 20 Jahren. Und deswegen würde ich sagen, so als Medium sehe ich zumindest für einen Ballesterer die Verantwortung, das auch so weiterzumachen. Ich würde nicht ausschließen, dass dann ich irgendwann sage, okay, ich kann mich mit dem nicht auseinandersetzen, ich pack das einfach nimmer. Und ich habe schon so oft die Hoffnung gehabt, dass mir der Fußball noch mehr zurückgibt oder was auch immer. Das ist das eine. Aber ich würde sagen, dass die Notwendigkeit für das Medium genau dort hinzuschauen und zu sagen, und auch die Dinge auch noch zu suchen oder auch vielleicht zu schauen, findet man sie noch? Also irgendwie um das Karlswendung da irgendwie an auch wieder aufzugreifen. Ich glaube, die Aufgabe wird nicht weniger.
Okay, da habt ihr mir jetzt ein bisschen Hoffnung gegeben. Ich wollte auch nicht so negativ aus dieser Sendung rausgehen, deswegen hatte ich sowieso noch eine weitere Frage abschließend im Hinterkopf und zwar ein bisschen jetzt aus der Hüfte geschossen. Aber was sind eure liebsten Erinnerungen, wenn ihr an eure Zeit bei 20 Jahre Ballesterer, wenn auch nicht komplett dabei, Jakob schon klar, und 20 Jahre Freunde zurückdenkt? Jakob, du musst vorlegen, was ist deine Lieblingsanekdote, die du erlebt hast, ein Ereignis, was du nicht missen wollen würdest, was dir mit dem Ballesterer passiert ist?
Also jetzt, von einer persönlichen Geschichte her, würde ich sagen, das ist jetzt auch nichts besonders Schönes oder so gewesen, aber ich würde sagen, das prägendste für mich, oder das wichtigste Erlebnis war sicherlich 2008 gemeinsam mit dem Reinhardt, meinem Vorgänger, die Napoli-Fans nach Rom begleitet haben zum ersten Spiel der Saison. Und bei dem Spiel hat es halt alle möglichen Schwierigkeiten gegeben, also damals waren Sonderzüge in Italien schon verboten, Trinitalia hat aber trotzdem eigentlich einen eingerichtet, es war Hochsommer, heiß, schwierig, eine Auswärtsfahrt mit allen möglichen Schikanen quasi. Und herausgekommen ist dann, dass das Ganze erzählt worden ist, so okay, wieder mal die Napoli-Fans und wieder mal es hat Ausschreitungen gegeben und was auch immer. Relativ viel ist dort eigentlich nicht passiert. Medial oder massenmedial ist das halt alles die Erzählung von den italienischen Bahnen und von der Polizei quasi übernommen worden. Der Innenminister hat noch am selben Abend mehr oder weniger gesagt, okay, Napoli-Fans dürfen jetzt eine Saison auch nicht auswärtsfahren. Riesenthema überall. Und der Rheinland und ich waren da halt irgendwie mittendrin und haben dann quasi mit Kollegen vom Standard einer Tageszeitung gesprochen und gesagt, Leute, wenn euch das interessiert, wir wären da, wir könnten dazu was sagen. Und das Ganze hat sich dann, mit der Zeit ist es dann in Italien wieder aufgegriffen worden, ist dann wieder zurückgekommen und wir haben wahnsinnig viel Feedback oder positive Meldungen bekommen von Leuten, die sagen, okay, na irgendwie ist da ja vielleicht doch was anderes passiert als das, was kommuniziert worden ist. Es ist dann ein Fernsehteam der Reihe gekommen, hat uns in Wien in der alten Redaktion auch besucht, es ist unser Bericht irgendwie im italienischen Parlament zitiert worden, also das war so, würde ich sagen, wahrscheinlich irgendwie für die Geschichte meines Lebens. Da war ich gerade zwei Jahre dabei, also vielleicht zu früh gekommen. Wenn sie später gekommen wäre, dann hätte ich vielleicht auch besser gewusst, wie man Geschichten schön erzählt oder so. Aber da würde ich sagen, ich meine, das ist jetzt nicht so die klassische Anekdote, aber das ist so ein total prägendes Erlebnis, das mich mit meinen Jahren im Ballestra natürlich verbindet.
Damals hat Kai Tippmann dazu geschrieben, der war auch schon hier im Rasenfunk zu Gast in seinem Blog, glaube ich, hat er das geschrieben. Eine kleine Redaktion eines 20.000 Auflageplatz hatte mal eben den millionenschweren Redaktionsstuben die Unterhosen heruntergezogen, weil ihr eben zufällig da mit dabei wart und dann die Berichterstattung korrigieren konntet, um es mal so zu sagen.
Ja, nein, genau, also war wirklich Wahnsinn. Also auch, würde ich sagen, nicht geplant ist besser als im Traum das hier.
Sowas gibt es auch mal. Philipp, was ist deine liebste Erinnerung an 20 Jahre, Freunde?
Ich glaube gar nicht, dass es so die eine Anekdote gibt, aber…
Du kannst auch zehn erzählen, wir haben Zeit.
Das ist das Schönste, was ich wirklich bei der Arbeit von Elfreund immer wieder sehe, dass man die ganzen Helden von damals, die man so aus dem Fernsehkannte plötzlich dann in Natura trifft und überprüfen kann, ob das wunderbare Bild, das man von diesen Leuten hatte, ob das wirklich stimmt. Karl-Heinz Förster, ein großes Idol meiner Jugend. Ich habe mir sogar die Haare so gekämpft wie Karl-Heinz Förster. Ich fand den ganz großartig, den Treter mit dem Engelsgesicht, wie es so schön hieß, und der entpuppte sich dann als wahnsinnig netter, umgänglicher Typ. Lothar Matthäus war genauso, wie man ihn sich vorstellt. Man denkt immer, der ist komplett anders, aber dann ist er genauso und hat in dem Hotel in Budapest auch gleich die Kellnerin angebaggert und seine damalige Ehegattin weggedrückt am Telefon. Solche Sachen fand ich immer echt sehr, sehr schön. Aber tatsächlich hat mir Ewald Lin, der ja ein Freund des Hauses geworden ist, einen Kindheitstrauma quasi entledigt. Denn 1982 bin ich mit meinem Bruder zum Eröffnungstraining von Arminia gegangen auf der Radrennbahn in Bielefeld und wollte ein Autogramm haben und alle gaben noch welche, Larger Pol und Helmut Schröder und Wolfgang Kneipp usw. Aber Ewald Lin schaute uns an und sagte, mein Autogramm ist doch nicht mehr wert als eures. Unterschreibt ihr doch selber, euer Autogramm ist genauso wert. Und mein Bruder Ronald, ich guckte uns an und sagte, Ewald, das ist dein Autogramm, das ist tausendmal mehr wert als unseres. Dann habe ich Ewald Lin im Zuge einer Reportage 2003 mal getroffen und dann erzählte ich ihm etwas im Überschwang diese Geschichte, worauf mich Ewald Lin dann erstmal nur in einer Mischung aus Spott und Verachtung anguckte und meinte, es wird ja wohl ihre persönliche Entwicklung nicht allzu gehemmt haben, dass ich ihnen kein Autogramm gegeben habe. Und dann meinte ich, nein, nein. Dann zog ich von dann und neulich, da hatten wir noch mal eine Veranstaltung gemeinsam, da hatten wir dann endlich ein Autogramm gegeben. Und das war – eigentlich hätte ich danach den ganzen Bums dicht machen können, weil schöner kann es nicht mehr werden.
Die Initialzündung war das verwehrte Autogramm von Ewald Lin 1982. Man weiß es nicht, ob er bis hierhin gekommen ist. Aber solche Geschichten schreibt einfach nur der Fußball und solche Geschichten schreibt nur ihr in Elfreund und im Ballesterer. Ich danke euch beiden sehr, dass ihr euch trotz Homeoffice, trotz technischer Probleme, die es anscheinend jetzt bei jeder Rasenfunkaufzeichnung während Corona gibt, man kann sich vorstellen, woran das liegt, dass ihr euch die Zeit genommen habt. Ich empfehle nochmal sehr gerne an dieser Stelle das große Elfreunde-Buch. Erschienen bei Heiner Hardcover. 456 Seiten für 25 Euro. Sehr schön. Vor allem, als du vorhin von dem erotischen Verhältnis zu Print gesprochen hast, da fies mir wieder ein. Ich habe hier immer wieder darin herum geblättert. Und es riecht einfach so geil. Es ist einfach diese... Es ist einfach so. Es kommt dazu bei Printmagazinen. Da lasse ich mir von niemandem was anderes erzählen. Frisch gekaufte Bücher oder Magazine. Da kommt noch etwas euphaktorisches dazu. Also kann ich sehr empfehlen, ein sehr schönes Buch mit mega tollen Bildern. Aber das wusste man ja bei Freunde auch schon, dass es das sein würde. Also Philipp, vielen Dank, dass du dir Zeit genommen hast. Danke natürlich auch an Jakob Rosenberg. Unterstützt alle den Ballesterer. Ich denke, ihr habt mehr als nur einen Grund gehört in den vorangegangenen Zeit. Warum man den Ballesterer unterstützen sollte, werdet ihr Teil des Ballesterer-Supporters-Clubs. Jakob, vielen Dank, dass du mit dabei warst. Und ich drücke euch alle Daumen, dass ihr dem Trend etwas entgegensetzen könnt. Und dass wir dann irgendwann in 20 Jahren die 40 Jahre Show machen, wo wir dann auch wissen, was aus dem Rasenfunk geworden ist. Ob ich wirklich verzweifelt bin an allem. Danke dir, Jakob, dass du mit dabei warst.
Herzlichen Dank und ich freue mich auf die nächste Sendung in 20 Jahren.
Vielleicht kriegen wir es ja auch ein bisschen früher hin. Danke euch beiden. Danke euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Podcast-Grüße können natürlich jetzt nur rausgehen an die wilde Liga, der Podcast von Elfreunde, den man normalerweise nicht so einfach hören kann, weil er bei Audible hinterlegt ist. Aber aktuell, und damit meine ich jetzt im März 2020, ist Audible für jeden frei zugänglich. Also kann man auch mal die wilde Liga hören. Tut es, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, und hört natürlich auch gerne den Rasenfunk. Ich freue mich, wenn ihr bald mal wieder mit dabei seid. Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch. Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Punkthäuser.